what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
yo what's going on people King rich is
back again with another podcast good
evening and hi and welcome to Auntie
Jenny's Village Jenny's podcast it's
your boy The Fresh Prince of someone
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how can
everyone have someone out there for
themselves
breaking it is to find somebody you're
compatible with that you'd like not yes
of your same generation and that likes
the same things that you do go in there
having fun okay okay then then get out
then get out
I'm not here to get canceled today
I'm submissive and you'll be surprised
because I will say what I want to say
now and I'll say what I want to say with
my mind but my demeanor doesn't change
and I'm gonna look down on him because
at the end of the day whoever you're
with is a reflection of you what has
happened to society that has made the
normal man a waste man I would feel so
bad asking a guy to buy like a three
thousand dollar bag
[Music]
[Applause]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way and let's get started
a couple announcements before we start
the show I'm the first guys we have two
clips channels just pearly clips and
pearl daily make sure you go and
subscribe to both also guys um go
subscribe to wife school we just had an
episode come out where I learned to need
bread
um also guys um there's a Google form
we're going to be doing meetups in
London so make sure you sign up to our
Google form
also we have four membership tiers um
how many likes to open up the chat today
King what are we thinking 1 500 1 500
likes today and we will open up the chat
um second tier guys you could do our
Discord and our behind the scenes Vlogs
and also our members only videos
um if you want to see me freestyle rap
sign up for the second tier also guys um
third tier you get to connect with me on
social media and fourth year you get a
one-on-one call with me one once a month
want to know how to get a million
subscribers in a year sign up for that
tier also guys um they banned my first
Instagram just pearly things so follow
my second Instagram just pearly things
one I'm also back on Tick Tock um as you
know they took away not one not two not
three not four but five of my Tick Tock
so go follow my new one which is just
pearly things um they gave me back my
original username which which was
exciting but
um also we have an animation Channel
just for the animation so go follow that
as well
um and what are we what are we uh saving
for we're saving for a kickout cam right
how much is a kick out cam how much are
we saving
two thousand pounds okay we're trying to
get 2 000 more pounds so I can get a
kick out camera
um as you know we kicked someone out
last show which isn't gonna happen the
show I'm sure oh thank you because we
have very nice nice panel today but we
did and we couldn't even we couldn't
even video it because we don't have a
kick out cam very soon I know I know so
so
um today
um we have a lovely panel so why don't
we go around everyone say your name your
age your relationship status and a fun
fact about yourself starting here go
around and then we'll do second row
hi guys I'm Tara do I need to say the
age
yeah yeah name Angela okay 34. uh
and uh what else did you want me to tell
you relationships I see a ring no no
babe this is wrong fingers single single
okay go ahead
yeah all right guys
um Billy Reed and my age is 45 and my
relationship status is single and I work
with mostly women
hi guys my name is Loretta Lyon and I am
ancient if I may say that I feel like
sometimes I'm 43 but wisdom-wise I am
ancient I am a mother of two and I've
got a husband yes I know sorry guys
and fun things about me is just that I
don't take anything too seriously
because life taught me some hard lessons
so I'm always fun
I know you Mia yeah yeah oh yeah um I'm
ty Mitchell I'm 32 my relationship
status is also single and I'm a boxer
I'm the notorious MLD
I'm 37 years old single fun fact about
me it is my fifth day in London not
stabbed really happy about that
I'm confused okay
um go ahead a second uh yeah my name is
Daniel everyone called me Franklin come
wherever you want I'm 27 years old just
turned 27 recently fun fact about myself
from six foot five
uh Troy Francis I am 47 years old I'm a
dating coach based in London uh single
sadly still even though I keep
announcing it on this show
and uh fun facts about me I spent the
weekend in Lisbon for the first time
ever and it's really good really cool
City so I'd recommend it guys nice
people I go about beard gang 28 taken
and uh as you know I've been connecting
bids since 2019. shoot
okay guys another announcement another
announcement I forgot I went on talk TV
today with three feminists I had a lot
of I had a lot of fun so that's going to
come out on you know what the channel
was is it just on the talk TV channel
when did they say it would come out like
a week
I guess whenever they feel like putting
it out but it was I had it it was fun
right I thought that was fun oh I had a
lot of fun a lot of wow so um today's
today's
um
topic was inspired by MLD
you know he went on a podcast and when
he talked about you should endure in a
relationship so today we're going to
talk about what should you endure in a
relationship so my first question is um
do you believe in marriage and do you
believe in divorce
I do believe in marriage
um just haven't really had a chance to
meet my person so
divorce I believe in anything that makes
two people happy you know it's it's not
something you pre-planned just sign a
contract agreement and that that's it so
yeah well whatever happens as long as it
works with both okay so you do believe
in divorce well I would prefer not to
have a divorce that's probably why I'm
still choosing but uh if it happens it
happens okay so I'm just I just want to
know you do believe in divorce in some
situations yes in some situations okay
fine so yeah I believe in marriage
divorce not so much okay it's that's not
a fun thing I'm going through divorce
okay so towards just finish completing
now so really I think with most guys
we'll stick it out for the rough the
troughs and the the highs and the lows
but maybe uh the experience in modern in
the modern world is possibly uh women
are less patient
okay I stick it out so it sounds like it
wasn't really your choice no it wasn't
no it was no choice oh actually
well it was it Mutual it was in the end
yeah yeah it was Mutual okay uh well now
that I think about it yeah how is it how
is it Mutual in the end so she brought
it up and then like you well later like
I don't know how I was just curious I
was one-sided then Mutual well okay
let's get raw with it so
every time we pretty much had an
argument she she was calling an end to
the marriage each time and then after 50
times of saying I'm I don't want to be
in this anymore I was like okay oh okay
like like I've done okay I'm done with
this okay
yeah it's kind of an extreme version
okay but I've learned so much from it
okay uh what about you do you believe in
marriage and do you believe in divorce I
I grew up in a society that marriage was
a must in order to be with someone and I
respect that and that's fine my parents
have been together forever and it's good
they're happy and not sometimes but
they're still together
do I believe in divorce I believe in
doing the right thing what feels right
for people because I was so into like no
divorce it shouldn't happen but then
over the years and working with people
that have come because can I just very
quickly give some background I I was you
know I have a very sort of
different way of looking at stories
because um I was kidnapped and then
abused and so on you know and eventually
when I made it through to the UK after
my kidnap it was very difficult for me
to to to form those relationships
whether it's friendship trust or even
getting married So eventually I got
married and I'm happy and everything is
fine but then I work with people and
they haven't gone through War they
haven't gone through kidnap but they
they can relate to my story and I say
why could you relate they said because
I've got war going on in the house so if
there is war in the house it's
completely unfair for children to be
exposed to something that is so toxic so
if you recognize it's toxic you also
have the the ability to say no to what's
happening to you and therefore you
should go for what feels right so you
should not be selfish in terms of
thinking by staying in that relationship
that you are doing a favor by keeping
the kids in that relationship or even if
their kids are not involved do you want
to be in a relationship that's toxic
so I believe in marriage and I believe
in divorce and I stand by it because
only for the right reasons I don't mean
Changing Partners I don't mean you know
just just divorce because you feel like
it because the grass looks Greener but
the grass is not greener on the other
side okay so you do believe in divorce I
believe in divorce for those reasons yes
okay so what what reasons do you believe
in for example if there is violence if
okay you've drifted away and you've
really genuinely unhappy okay so if you
drifted apart you don't feel like you
did before
well I mean we all don't feel the same
as we do at the beginning but I mean
more like in a sense that one has grown
and the other one has stayed stagnant
okay so therefore if you feel like
you're not on the same page anymore so
they're no longer you are friends
because relationships is friendship how
does one grow and one stay stagnant like
what does that mean
um well for example if one grows in
terms of following their dreams or
following that what they want to do with
their career and the other one just
decides to be forever the same but they
then go against the other person hold
the other person back or they get a bit
funny about it I mean there's something
isn't that usual isn't that usually what
happened like one person goes for their
Career One watches the kids usually I
think she's what I think she means like
when you're too because this happened to
me when you're in a relationship with
someone and one person is a little bit
more focused on self-development and the
other person is kind of content with
their life
um when you turn when you start to
ascend and level up as a person like
you're it's up to you in my particular
experience as a man to pull your woman
up with you and you guys level up
together because eventually if you don't
level up there is going to be a gap
between the two of you and eventually
you're going to grow apart over the
years I think is that what you mean no
absolutely I was getting there but I'm
aware of time and everybody should have
their say but have been in a marriage
and having been for me took a lot to be
in a marriage and trust a man and create
life again because I was you know
really
badly bruised in so many ways because I
don't you know I don't want to get into
it but you can read the book about it
but
it takes courage to to give yourself
fully in a relationship so I think both
parties should appreciate the fact that
we are both vulnerable when you open up
and you say you love each other and love
means a lot more a lot not just like you
know yeah I just don't yeah I just don't
if we're talking about like kids I just
don't know if you should get divorced
over self-development like one person
develops one doesn't no so yeah I'm
talking more as the two people
because I'm married and I have seen I
had my husband live in Singapore for a
while on his own and I raised the boys
and I've sacrificed my career so many
times and I even moved to Singapore and
had to set up a business from scratch so
you you do those things because you you
love each other and you support each
other I'm not saying just because you're
growing apart and and you should get
divorced but if you are miserable and
the kids can feel it
I mean it's it's a good idea to to get
divorced okay to speak about it and
decide what's best okay what do you
think yeah I definitely believe in
marriage I'm a Muslim and it's a big
part of our religion to get married
um getting married actually completes
half our faith that's how the importance
of marriage in Islam so I definitely
believe in it I also believe in divorce
and uh like as a last resort
um divorce is the most hated Thing by
Allah that's that's legal so it should
be our last resort but in certain
situations yeah divorce is needed in
some situations if um a man's beating
his wife for example she should not
definitely stay stay in a marriage but
um
but as a whole yeah I think um you
should you should try and work through
things I think we live in a uh a
generation now where we're just quitters
whether it be it works something hard
relationships just life I think we're
um a nation of quitters at the moment
and I think life's life's not easy
marriage definitely isn't easy and I
think
he should really really work through
things and really try your best to try
and get through things before divorce
but I think as a last resort yeah I'm I
think divorce is sometimes needed but I
think marriage is a beautiful thing okay
what do you think I definitely believe
in marriage I want to get married
without getting the state and my assets
involved but um when it comes to divorce
I'm half Indian and I like to refer back
to my Indian people with the less than
one percent divorce rate uh I definitely
just think that a lot of people right
now
they would rather point the finger at
somebody
and pull the rug on a relationship
and want to get a divorce quickly
compared to working it out sitting down
taking accountability on both parties
for the re for their actions and no I'm
not saying that if a woman is getting
beaten in a relationship she should stay
or a man because that's what the
detractors like to say they like to take
the most extreme example
and act as if it's a blanket statement
to all people who are having troubles in
relationship but I do believe the
majority of people who get divorces I
believe that the majority of those
people could work through their
differences however we live in this
gigantically selfish narcissistic
culture nowadays around the world
and I think everybody's talking about me
me me me but the thing about focusing on
me me me me that's who you end up with
you end up alone and you need to be more
mature as a human as an individual and
you need to focus on we not me so you
should [__] endure
[Laughter]
what do you think do you believe in um
do you even believe in marriage and do
you believe in divorce well I've
recently got engaged so congratulations
Daniel she's going to endure
I do believe in marriage I think
marriage is is one of those things where
like it's part of everyone well it
should be a part of most people's life
cycles is one of those is two souls
coming together to make one story and
make one future together which is
beautiful in his own sense divorce on
the other hand
um It's Tricky one because no fault
divorces I don't believe it and I think
that's kind of the Crux of a lot of
people's arguments because enough
thought divorce is just I I will not
into each other as much as we used to be
I'm a dip and I'm still going to take
off your stuff
as I leave
that side of it I'm not really a fan of
I do I do believe in divorce in dire in
like you like said earlier it as a last
resort in the stage of like like a lot
of going on because life is a lot of
going on and life is a lot of things but
like if
it was the last resort and and your life
is in danger then leave but like yeah
but whatever like if it's one of those
things but even in that in that
situation not to drone on too much you
always have it's also even trickier
because bringing up the abuse thing
there are two sides of this a he was
always kind of abusive and you let it go
which then I have to ask you why did you
marry this person or B he wasn't abusive
and he became abusive in the
relationship at some point in which I
have to ask what happened because people
who don't aren't aren't aggressive and
then suddenly turn aggressive that's a
case study right that it should be a
case study at least because not every
people who aren't violent don't have the
propensity for violence so if they start
doing that this has to be a underlying
reason as to why that happened I saw it
I saw a video of a girl that was
taunting a guy about his dead son and
then he hit her who abused who she did
yeah
emotional abuse both people emotional
abuse is the same I mean the reason I I
stay a little bit away from both people
the wrong answer which is 100 right but
he shouldn't have hit her but it's like
it's the product is to put the bad thing
you know what I mean like if you put
like okay if you're in the woods and you
see a bear sleeping and you poke that
bear it's just to wake up and it kills
you who's fault is it yeah the Bear's
full for waking up and killing you and
realizing it's a bear and you're a human
and why are you bugging me or you for
bugging that bear continuously until it
woke up and realized you were there I
think it's just like kind of a
difference between like men
understanding men like I would never
talk [__] to this guy oh God
because this guy [__] me up but you
know some girls would be like [__] you
and your tattoos and your ripped jeans
or whatever you know like we talked
about it yesterday and it was funny
because that girl actually she did it we
say like in an argument a woman will
make a conversation personal and she
started to pick personal shots against
me and then you don't understand like in
man world if you do certain things that
it could lead to violence I'm not saying
violence is is an okay thing but when
you do doing certain things to provoke
violence you shouldn't be shocked when
violence happens in understanding that
we have between us exactly understanding
yeah
well I just I just genuinely believe if
you're in a toxic relationship both
people are playing a part you're right
and I just think it's very rare in my
opinion that it's just one-sided he's
hitting her with no provoke no provoking
yeah it's not like he just walks into
the kitchen he's like what is this tuner
casserole I'm not saying it doesn't
happen but I just think that the the
default should be try to work it out
always that should be the default
because it goes back to it goes back to
the two questions was he hitting you
from the beginning or did he just stop
both of things that you need to figure
out why and and the reasons that you're
in the situation and I think the main
question sorry I'm doing a good job and
I wouldn't add it to which you said
Pearl like people should work and work
it through because what happens in
today's modern culture right when they
when you break up with somebody
they say oh yeah the best way to get
over someone is to get under someone
else right because we have all these
modern devices that let us cope
with avoiding a responsibility for the
relationship failure like back in the
90s you know 80s 90s whatever
pre-internet when someone dumped you you
had to sit at home like damn
well I suck like what did I do wrong now
you're like it wasn't my fault you get
on Tinder you get on Bumble you get on
hinge and you're just looking for
someone else to tell you you're great
instead of taking a moment to reflect on
why you [__] up in this relationship
and then guess what you just carry your
trauma your bad [__] into the next
relationship and people do that they
monkey Branch you know they go from
relationship to relationship
relationship next thing you know you're
in your late 30s you're single and
you're like damn
what the [__] did I do with my life some
people in their 40s 50s I've seen this
happening over lifetimes you know am I
in my experience it it all comes down to
choices
so you may have got you may be in a
relationship where you're suffering
abuse but you chose that person
originally and there would have been
Clues to the red flags yes yeah which
you ignored when you were feeling you
know something oh I Feel Love for this
person it's so cute and I just feel
fluffy never mind that he's rude to the
the the the the the waiter never mind
that it you know is instantly jealous
never mind you know ignore all those
things and then later on down the line
they all these red flags come flying out
and you're like oh my God where did this
cover I can't believe this oh my God I'm
being attacked but but you made the
choice originally and you chose to
ignore I work with a lot of clients and
they discover when I work them and say
were the clues there at the beginning oh
my God yes it was there but their
experiences I I everything was fine we
got together and then it just went
started to turn bad because that goes
back to the narcissism of today's time
everybody thinks to the exception to the
rule they're like I see this red flag
but I mean I got this everybody thinks
they can crowbar I can change him
genuinely have no sympathy for girls
that tell me they're in a toxic
relationship you there is no way it was
one-sided I don't believe you when you
say oh I had no idea he was a cheater it
just came out of nowhere no I don't
believe you no your last three
boyfriends weren't toxic it's probably
you I just don't believe it but they
generally believe it until you start to
pinpoint and point out all the clues
that join the dots we're like oh yeah
yeah but I think I think actually
raising a hand against a woman is a hard
Red Line though to be to be honest
and look I mean you could say well there
were indications there before and she
should have picked up on them and etc
etc But ultimately the dude who does
that I think he's a scumbag and I think
that I think that's you know do you
think even in the situation that I was
saying do you think he's like just a
scumbag when because that's what we
don't we don't talk about because we
never have a conversation about like
women that verbally abused men and women
I think yeah and I I know what you're
saying I can understand but actually
like striking a woman can like it's not
I think I think I mean it's it's such a
tenor because I mean it's it's funny
isn't it because toxic masculinity gets
talked about a lot and you know men are
you know increasingly demonized and
everything else but I mean it seems to
me I mean I was brought up like in the
UK right and you know it was instilled
in everybody you do not raise a hand
against a woman do you know what I mean
and so I think firstly that the number
of guys who actually do that is
incredibly small you know subject
contrary to what the belief in the
culture seems to be that men are these
kind of like violent beasts who are sort
of just on the Rampage the whole time I
think that's an incredible minority but
I do think that that ultimately yeah I
mean she shouldn't have talked to the
guy like that it's absolutely horrendous
but ultimately you shouldn't raise your
head against a woman I do think that's
wrong in terms of do I do I believe in
marriage absolutely no it's a terrible
idea
a possible bro what are you doing
no no no I think I think the problem
with legal marriage as a few people have
said I think there's a big problem with
that and I think fundamentally you are
putting illegal contract oh to contain
something that is this romantic
emotional thing as we have it now and I
think that's a mistake because feelings
change and and blah blah blah and you
know and what what John talks about in
terms of the Indian sort of arranged
marriage thing
when you take the romance out of the
equation and you guys it's almost more
of a contractual thing that can sort of
work I think what we're trying to do now
is we're trying to base a legal contract
on feelings yeah and we're also in a
culture that basically encourages people
not to respect that anymore so so there
when we come to the question of divorce
do I believe in divorce well under
certain circumstances yes but I do think
if you've got to the stage where you've
been in the church or the registry
office or whatever it is with that
person and you've made that agreement
and then you know five years down the
line you're saying oh well actually you
know I'm kind of not feeling it anymore
you know we're on different paths so I'm
out I think that is a bad thing I think
once you've made that commitment and I
think people should think very carefully
about whether they do need to make that
commitment certainly legal sense but
once you've made it you really you
should stay in there do you know what I
mean unless the circumstances are are
pretty extreme so I do agree that the
divorce thing is people I think like
John said you know people we're all
we're all too quick to quit that's the
problem in this day and age we're all
too quick to quit and it's too easy for
us to quit so you don't believe in
marriage
so don't believe in divorce absolutely
makes perfect sense perfect sense
no he does it makes absolutely perfect
sense because I think fundamental the
first thing is you should think as
particularly as a guy like you know come
on guys you can get a passport you can
go to Columbia what's the problem here
you know
um so firstly you've got to think
carefully about that is this what I
actually want in the first place and
then secondly is is a legal document
what I want that's the next thing you
know is there another way to to make
that long-term commitment in a
relationship with somebody without
getting the state involved that's the
second thing but
if you've crossed that Rubicon and you
have made that commitment then you've
made a promise to somebody and you know
you've also if you're doing in a
religious context you made a promise in
front of God and then five years down
the line you're just gonna say I'll stop
that it doesn't matter you know so I am
just I kind of half agree with you I
think if I wasn't religious and it
wasn't for religious reasons I think if
you're not religious and you're a man
and you want to get married I think it's
there's no point in any benefits the
woman because if me to get married is a
is between is forgot I don't care about
Boris Johnson whoever the prime minister
is like I don't wanna they need to sign
a document however in Islam we don't get
like you know you get married here and
you sign the registry whatever it's not
like that in Islam so if we get divorced
can't take half of nothing yeah yeah I
would never get married married like I
can get married in this country she's my
wife but I wouldn't get married where
it's like a legal contract binding in
the country it's just a contract between
us two and God because that's what
marriage is about anyway yeah yeah I
would never like some Muslim women and
some Muslim couples they get married
islamically and they also get married
um legally I never get married legally
no way you don't benefit the woman I've
never put myself in a situation yeah
where a woman could take half a month it
would never happen it's the legacy of
the government anything the government
touches
just [__] sucks like you know sorry
so let me get this straight basically
old man and I'm scared of marriage
because you have to share half with the
woman no not share house when you it's
when you divorce the reason give half
the reasons about the marriage why do
you think about divorce because you have
to be like because because the women are
women women divorce 80 of the time one
of the number one reasons is financial
you know and there's also great
incentive for women to falsely accuse
men of abuse in this country because
they offer them free lawyers and it's
really common they also only get access
to their kid maybe 20 of the time so I
think I think what's more scary actually
to men is not being able to see their
children I think that is absolutely
something they should be afraid and
economically speaking too so divorce
when you are subsidizing divorce right
anything the government subsidizes it
grows and that's why right now in the UK
the United States Australia Canada right
single mother households are growing
because there is a financial incentive
if I could marry us a good-looking woman
who's rich as [__] and I could trick her
like three to five years and divorce her
and take half of her Millions there are
guys out there that would do that what's
happening it's just on the other side
there's the shoes on the other foot in
the situation
safeguards against that the other
problem is you're kind of it's almost
like going into casino and betting on 50
50 isn't it like is this woman and I
guess you could say the other way for
argument's sake but as a guy's
perspective is this woman gonna she's
made this promise to me we're gonna be
together and this is gonna be it but how
do I know that in 10 15 years down the
line she's not going to be thinking well
actually do you know what I'm kind of
not really feeling it anymore and my
friends say I could do better and I
deserve to you know it's you know one
life
it's over a stupid reasons yeah
if you can dump somebody and get a fat
payout like you know how much you know
how many guys would be so happy we have
a generation of just like selfish wives
because they think about their feelings
before their kids it's not about you
it's about the children a word that gets
banded around a lot is happiness in
marriage and I say to people why did you
get married for hap like who said that
marriage will bring happiness
it's not one of the reasons why people
stay together for 20 25 years for a
lifetime let's say I stayed with him
because I was consistently happy you'd
never hear that well that's a problem
life is and downs isn't it
they want to be happy the whole time and
to and to answer like why would guys be
afraid of divorce like on top of that so
literally a girl can make one phone call
and get a restraining order on a guy and
kick him out of a house that he pays for
and now he's pissed so then he this is
like to the average guy he's paying for
a mortgage on a house that he does he's
not even living in it takes him like six
months to a year a lot of times to even
get to go to court yeah like and so now
on top of that during that time she can
also with no evidence put him on child
support so now he's on child support and
he can't he's paying a mortgage on a
house that wasn't his are you talking
about rotten apples
I'm talking about rotten apples no it's
it's a lot more so I could see how on
the outside looking and you might think
that because I mean probably because
I've never been married and you know you
kind of killing my dreams imagine
imagine like would you agree that like
women can be spiteful of course and like
you are the worst version of yourself
when you feel really wronged by a guy
right every girl like if she feels
really wronged by a guy like she does
crazy things like why do you why do you
hear girls say oh he made me crazy
right I wouldn't say that I'm not
talking about you I'm talking about
women and so it's like you're giving
women a ton of power when they're the
worst version of themselves and a lot of
women to like do it yeah like I think
about this too like let's say you're
let's say you and I are married right
and you really love me oh hello and then
wait a second
just just bear with me on this one okay
this is the first marriage yes so let's
just say you're married to a guy right
yeah and then
you catch him cheating
and then he says well I'm cheating
because of you and then he divorces you
and then you gotta pay for his mortgage
and you have to give him monthly alimony
payments and child support payments
while you're watching him with his new
girl side piece awesome carrying my
child just listen because if he is just
let me let me let me let me finish this
let me just calm down what I'm trying to
say is like imagine and then you have to
watch on Instagram every day him with
the new girl and you know you're
financing their trips to Italy and them
having a good time their relationship
photos and all that yeah but is that
fair yes but did he carry my child did
he carry it for nine months
moment guys it's not about entitlements
I promise you why should we have to look
after your child
as well yes so when you have your child
you look after him or her and when I've
got him I'll look after him why should I
have to pay for you to look after your
own child you don't pay me when I have
my child
are we in the same exactly yes
and I'm saying I'm saying when we split
up this is not about when we split up
okay okay you're talking about so say if
you split up for example and he's been
caught cheating and then imagine now
you're having to pay for your ex-partner
you've split up
you've got his new side piece in the
house you have to pay for this
that's what I'm saying like how many
times have you how many times have you
dated a guy and then you were stalking
him and then you saw the new girl he's
with and you just made me so angry I
don't stalk them usually they stalk me
[Applause]
guys I've got I've got two case studies
to basically explain why to give an
answer to this Mary J Blige and Adele
the reason I bring these two women up
are these are two women who got divorced
and took the males perspective of having
to pay their Partners half rather than
men paying them what happened
the entire incident called both those
her ex-husbands perceives Cloud chases
money hungry they said they were only
off their door for a month women did all
the time
the most famous the most richest women
in the world is only Rich because she's
divorced Bill Gates
do you understand
Jeff Bezos was a 30 billion dollars she
doesn't even know how to write code
that's crazy though I actually think it
affects like average guy like I feel
like billionaires like they always
recover they're fine yeah yeah no but
it's the average guy what it burned me
you haven't even if it was a few million
I just don't like the four of my ex
living in a house with a new man
hateful living in your house
I've heard that a few times I'm with you
I just I I think it like from the
documentary I've been doing it's like it
seems to affect average guys the most
because it's always like they worked for
20 years they're not the type of guys
that are going to be able to like build
that up or like make another million or
whatever so it like it wrecks them a lot
of guys commit suicide in the process
it's really sad
yeah yeah and I always find it as well
like in relationships when they break up
like
I that's what I said when I find women
so entitled for example I've got a
friend now best friend he's um going
through he's engaged but he's going for
a breakup and for some reason unbeknown
to me I don't know why he put his misses
his name on the house now they're going
for a breakup she never put nothing into
the house and I know all her friends are
like you deserve off that house because
she's entitled to it it's like an idiot
you deserve off that house this this is
bear in mind he's the best father ever
he goes to work gets up with cracking on
Pace for everything she pays for nothing
all she does is go out all of now she's
gonna get half of that she feels
entitled to it and there's going to be
nothing in society there's nothing wrong
with it are they spell she deserves I've
seen me even if I meet somebody and I've
got nothing I still don't believe she
deserves half even if we build it
together because it's safe it's my
company that I've made it with or
without you for example me boxing
I'm gonna Box by goddess to if I met you
or not you definitely deserve something
if we've built come from nothing and
I've built something with you you
definitely deserve something 100 we
don't deserve half because he wasn't
with me taking punches in the gym
because you and I want me shooting in
the gym
and on the flip side if I was with a
woman and she made way more Millions I
was together from nothing she made
Millions I don't just that's not my
money that's your money I'm not I would
never as a man I couldn't take that
anyway you know it's crazy I I think
women are so delusional they literally
think they were the reason he got right
they literally think they're like yeah I
held him down I and I'm just like well
he he was gonna do it with her with that
like the guys that are gonna make a ton
of money are gonna do it with her
without the woman it's not it's not
about you yeah I think he's I guess it
depends on the specific circumstances in
that relationship but I mean it's it's
just like it's so arbitrary because the
problem is we're basing everything on
fields aren't we that's the difficulty
and it's all very well to say well what
what woman would do that and blah blah
blah but but the truth of the matter is
it's just so easy for people now because
you've got this Eat Pray Love kind of
culture of like oh you know you just you
know it's fomo and you've only got one
life and you you know which is which is
true in a sense but I mean it's kind of
like if you're making that commitment
and you're saying to somebody hey I'm
gonna spend the rest of my life with you
and then you're actually incentivized to
leave and it's all sort of based in
feelings and look we know that
relationships have ups and downs do you
know what I mean like At first it's
great you know the first few years
amazing brilliant and then you know it
starts to maybe it dips a little bit it
starts getting a bit dull then maybe he
has problems at work or he you know he
has some health problems and stuff and
then she's like world you know what
maybe I could have done better and then
she could just leave on the turn of a
dime you know and that's the problem
that everyone's facing it's like it's
literally like walking to the casino but
that's why people should find their
match because if you are a
self-sufficient person and you grow and
you're not basically what we're talking
about right now is problems of those who
not doing us you know they're not doing
something so they just feel entitled to
have it but if you're if you're a person
who continuously grows and you actually
invest in yourself and your relationship
and your partner I I believe those those
lines become much much blurry because it
it's not really about who gets what
because I'm not there to take your money
I'm there because I'm there it's not
just for me it's not just about the
money though I mean that's a big
consideration but it's not just about
the money it's also about you know I'm
going to make an emotional commitment to
this person I'm gonna put everything on
the line for them in illegal contract
and then she could just decide in five
years time actually saw it you know and
the average check will divorce over
literally nothing over like over
literally nothing like her emotions if
she just isn't feeling it like we didn't
she both say if you're not happy in the
relationship you should be able to leave
yeah but it happened it's not a it's not
a hurdle I'm not talking about a hurdle
you know also not happy when you fall
down and scratch your knee I'm not happy
because I have beautiful legs but when
they get up tomorrow I know that it's
just a hurdle that I overtake right but
I'm saying marriage isn't about
happiness and so it's like why would the
average guy get married when two out of
the three women on the panel believe in
divorce but two of the two of the girls
here said didn't they
um along the lines of well if you guys
are growing in different directions then
divorce we said okay so in an abusive
situation then divorce should be allowed
absolutely everyone agrees with that
right but you guys also said oh but if
you guys are growing in the wrong
direction and that's a little bit
intangible isn't it what does that
really mean you know what I mean
it's very difficult no I agree with what
what the Loretta said earlier about you
know when because this happens with
friendships too at least for me
personally like when I I dedicated
myself to becoming the successful
individual that I am now it was day in
and day out wake up hit the gym eat
clean work work work I mean as a fighter
you probably understand the same thing
right you have to wake up every single
day because in the way the world is
structured your skill set whatever your
skill set have it is constantly being
deteriorated because there's always a
new and improved way of doing things
yeah so if you're an individual that is
working on yourself day in and day out
one you are going to grow apart because
they're going to be below you as you
continue to ascend and two resentment is
going to build on both ends of that
Spectrum in my opinion I don't disagree
with that but ultimately if you've got
married to them and you guys have signed
a commitment together it's a bit like
wow because that kind of goes back to
it's about being happy when it's about a
commitment yeah you know so I just yeah
and I don't really think that's as
common with them for men to say that as
it is for women like I think that's
usually code for IR earned to my husband
yeah because like look at the military
like if you sign up for the military and
I mean the majority of people don't
desert military because you'll go to
prison if you do right but I guarantee
there's people who wake up like I mean
how many people that storm Normandy were
like I'm really ready to storm Normandy
like I'm really just ready to charge
these German machine gun nests on this
impenetrable Fortress of this Normandy
Beach probably 99 if not 100 of those
guys didn't want to be there but they
understand they had a duty to God and
Country to make these things happen and
that's a masculine thing Duty you got to
get it done no matter what right if
you're in a boxing match and you're
you're you break your nose and your left
eye is swollen shut but you've got to
win the fight no matter what otherwise
you're going to lose and the outcome is
just not going to be beneficial to you
to your career to your social media to
Your sponsorship deals men got to get
things done that's that's a masculine
thing is duty to the cause no matter
what when we're jettising people into
space hoping to make it back on time you
know we can't just be like mid launch be
like listen I really enjoyed the NASA
training but like today I just don't
want to go to space like sorry the
country and all this government
financing is is depending on you so
that's the thing when you and I'm not
trying to say women have no sense of
Duty but I'm trying to say that marriage
is a commitment and again when you
incentivize people
to quit on something
some people are going to take it and
when you look at the bell curve of IQs
and 50 of people are 100 IQ or less you
look at a divorce rate you're kind of
like okay I kind of understand why
people are just easy right out I also
think that in my experience from what
I've seen I always find that
the females friends have a lot to do
with they're more likely to get divorced
I love this guy
12 times more likely to get divorced if
their friends do something like that yes
you're right even me I don't even so
some of my friends Partners they're not
really much I don't I wouldn't say I
dislike them but they're not really my
kind of people some of them some of them
are great some of them and when they go
through stuff I'll say no you should
stick if you've got kids together you're
like you've made a commitment like try
and work through it to the best even
time and time again and I know that
their friends are like you should just
leave him this and then I'm like even
though I don't really like this person I
know it's good for the children and it's
good for the family for them to to try
and work through it and I just think if
you're this person's like her friends
for example I think you do you really
care more about her or do you just
wanted to be single so she can live the
best life with you B she's got kids
she's got a family to raise why are you
even trying to incentivize her to leave
like that are you really a good friend
okay because misery loves company
do you believe in divorce
um to be honest It's just sad that
Common Sense isn't law because obviously
if a woman gets of a man they get
married
she cheats on him and then takes his
money that just doesn't make sense he
shouldn't hold up in a court of law
incentivizing bad behavior of course but
it's the reality we live in so the best
we can do as many is just to Choose
Wisely I think they used to right they
used to when you when when it was
you you couldn't do that before you
couldn't cheat on your husband before
like years ago and then expect to take
everything I think the Judge shouldn't
hold on a minute I think he's been a bit
out of order here but then they took
that away yeah that right they took that
right away so you could be as bad well
they used to you used to have to like
prove a reason to get divorced so you'd
have to show the judge yeah so divorce
divorce got a lot easier but also we're
living in this perfect storm aren't we
because we've also got social media all
you know Instagram we've got the dating
apps like there are so many we're
getting this stuff pumped to this the
whole time you know she's she's looking
at her Instagram she's looking at like
the you know like hot guys whatever
she's probably got she may still have
dudes like coming into her DMS whatever
like there's there's so much opportunity
being pumped to us the whole time
particularly women who obviously have
you know by and large more options than
guys do you know there's very little
incentive either from a societal basis
certainly not from a legal basis but
also and that coupled with the amount of
opportunities she's got why wouldn't she
just think oh things are getting a bit
tough do you know what Sonic I can get
some money out of there so then I'll go
on to the next one you know also yeah
women think that they have all these
options because naturally when they go
for a breakup with a man or they're
going through stuff they've got loads of
men flooded in the DMS but women are
quite naive they really think that these
men are going to marry are they say yeah
yeah these men yeah
have you watched me say that in fresh
I've not seen it no because I see I'm
like yeah look at this in my DM I'm like
yeah he wants to smash he just wants to
smash exactly no you don't have as many
options as you think they need to leave
your man that's good for you that's so
that was you might have it was a good
man for you initially you might be going
through some stuff you leave him and now
you wonder why you've got 30 bodies and
it's not even that you want to sleep
with these people you're just getting
sold a dream and you're too naive to
distinguish what's right and what's
wrong if a man has a good intention he's
gonna marry you yeah and that's that's
what really what he says is a thousand
percent correct because these girls
think like all these dudes are after me
and each dude is like my choice of a
perfect relationship it's like no the
majority of these guys I would bet 95 of
these guys just want to hit it and get
out of there yeah you know but they
they're so delusional because we lived
in this narcissistic culture and this is
not in a disc on women but it's just the
reality of the situation is pretty true
you have social media you have the
government you have movies you have
music you have video games telling women
24 7 365. you're amazing you can do
whatever you want there's no
consequences for what you can do mainly
because you're a woman so I feel sorry
for these girls because they believe
this [__] and they think like oh yeah I
just have all these infinite options
next thing you know they wake up they're
35 and they're crying on Tick Tock
because they're single this is why I
don't even invest so much into you know
Cosmetics well I just think it's either
we're equal or we're not yeah like you
either think you're an equal so behave
like an equal you don't need child
support you don't need alimony you're an
equal you're a man
um
what what percent actually pay 50 of the
bills you're equal that's your partner
right that's what everyone says here
this is my partner well I've seen a
number of Articles recently though by
older women who've who've divorced their
husbands you know and then it's like 10
years later and they're like oh [__] I
shouldn't have done that you know like I
thought I thought the pastures were
Greener and actually now I'm on my own
I'm you know I'm 50. the grass is not
greener on the other side of the fence
the grass is greener where you water it
endure
I have a question for the ladies
um should you listen to your husband
Point Blank period yes or no
foreign
no I mean it's a yes or no only
your husband says do something you don't
want to no I just refer back to you just
said that we're supposed to be equal so
you're gonna pay off the bills you're
gonna find that you're gonna fight the
burger loan it comes in the house honey
honey the last guy I stopped the last
guy you gotta go down there wait wait
wait do you want to be in like a 50 50
partnership is that your ideal
relationship
how would you get into a traditional
relationship with a 50 50 mindset no
it's not a 50 50 mindset I just
understand there are certain things
where uh we have a saying it's the man
is the head but the woman is the neck
you need both to to to to you know to
turn around it's not just that's like
feminist Christianity no no no it's not
about feminist but what I'm saying is it
takes two to tango okay I'll give you a
different one it takes two to tango so
it doesn't matter who leads if that one
doesn't move you don't get in the right
direction so I believe that there are
certain things where my man will stump
his foot and if it's important to him I
will respect him and I will take his
decision but sometimes there will be
things that are equally important to me
where I would like to find a counterpart
who understands me and says this is
important to her and therefore she's the
one in charge but that's still a 50 50
mindset but because a traditional
mindset is he has the final say no
matter what yes but it's not to say
he'll never give you your way but it's
still his choice like that's a
traditional mindset if you look at
writings of women like 150 years ago
like the answer would just be yes this
whole do I need to listen to my voice of
course of course it's a conflicted you
know I'm still 34. I grew up in a very
different Society but I'm still here I'm
still here today so of course I'm
absorbing but I'm learning what works
for me to be honest like I've listened
to everyone I agree with pretty much
everyone says because everyone has a
point but for me like say my biological
dad didn't stay with my mom he didn't he
left us but my stepdad and I call him
dads they've been together for 33 years
and thriving I'm still matching clothes
never been away from another travel they
hold hands and that's what I want and
when I was 25 unfortunately I lost my
fiance to cancer so after that I've been
through this like I still want to have
that what I've envisioned maybe as a
young girl is a teenager and I still
believe it's possible but of course I
still adopt and I'm still here today I
don't live in the past and I'm not
trying to be this new DM slide kind of
uh woman either do you know who said
that quote
the which one man is ahead with the
woman is neck tell me who said that
there's a Canadian actress named like
Ania vardalos basically it's very
popular in Russia we say that as a can
we dissect that phrase for a second
because I've been sitting here she's
divorced feminist actress of course oh
really
still I was literally that was about my
two months
you should take the biblical perspective
which is but the woman change that to
Tango it's about the movement the woman
the woman is the crown on a man's head
it's an accessory even with the tangle
oh wow because if you look if you just
look at Society if you just look at
listen because like it's like a game of
chess right
the game of chess the Game of Life
is to win
and sometimes the queen is the strongest
piece on the board yeah do you play
chess she's the strongest yeah but the
game isn't over if the queen dies yeah
sometimes you gotta sacrifice the queen
to make a win and then you take a pawn
and get him to the other side and then
she can become a queen yeah but we took
it I'm talking about couple Dynamics
when two people merge together I'm not
talking about the rest of the world of
course he died I still alive I'm still
living I'm not talking about I'm not
talking about your particular situation
my only like Point yeah I'm not I'm not
talking about your situation but I'm
saying what you said when I said should
you listen to your husband if it's not a
yes that's not a traditional mindset
no and I'm not saying that's wrong I'm
just saying you said you would prefer a
traditional relationship so I'm just
asking how you would get it no that's
not what I said I just said that I I
would I would because you didn't like
the 50 50 right yeah I don't like the 50
50 but that doesn't mean that I'm
sitting around and expecting for things
and I'm entitled no I didn't say you're
in town no I know I know I'm just trying
to explain yeah yeah I totally get you I
totally get all of you guys and I love
the the fact that we're actually talking
about it because you know sometimes
you're so sure about what you picture
for yourself or what you think of and
then you listen to another opinion and
you understand them and then you refer
back to yourself and you think wait a
second but and what do you think now and
I don't know but I believe that once
again there is no one clear rule of what
to say or how to do or how to behave
well want something that doesn't work in
one relationship may work in another
fundamentally should you should you it
goes back to the question should you
endure once you've made that commitment
in a marriage or not that's the
fundamental question isn't it yes
it takes two to tango sure sure you're
right but even in a Tango one person
leads one person follows even in any
two-man dance one person leaves one
person follows one people use that it
takes two to tangle thing it always gets
me because it's like you're skipping the
question the question is would you lead
would you would you follow his lead and
we're using two to tango which has one
leader and one follower but which one
are you are you the leader are you the
follower well that that's my point is
like man men don't want to get married
today because they can't get traditional
wives because most women won't it won't
say yes to that question can I ask a
question where are you where's your
background where are you from
um Russia Brazil Sweden oh no okay okay
whereabouts in Russia uh some Petersburg
nice okay I was there in 21 actually
spent a lot of time in Russia but that's
a very traditional no no no no but but
so you're coming you're coming
traditionally cheaters well no
not you not you but ironically
ironically the um the divorce rate in in
Russia is actually quite High isn't it
and Russian women get some of the most I
think Russian women get the most
abortions in the world
I'm basically looking at the countries
they're just you judging by population
not by actually hotel but there's 20
million in Russia
20 million in Russia 1.3 million in
Chinese
you can prove a number of things with
that stuff yeah yeah Vietnam's number
two I'm shocked Russia's number one
Vietnam's number it could be down to
Resource all sorts of stuff oh
exactly but I'm not sure what you were
trying to say this wasn't a personal
attack on you of course it's not a
personal attack on you no I'm not
worried about that but what I'm trying
to explain obviously you heard Russia
and you you had the which is fine
totally fine you know I still value
respect your opinion but what I'm saying
is I grew up in so many different
countries that it's very hard it's like
the same way when people ask me where
are you from and it's so hard for me to
answer where I'm from because when
you've lived in three four different
countries and I believe I'm a global
Citizen and I believe I can have a place
anywhere so it's not about that no
that's fair enough no it's it's about
adaption you adapt then I adapted also I
pick and choose from anything that I
like if I I believe that this oh I love
this this actually it's tough I'm
biracial too so they're like where are
you from like well yeah we break up
don't break out the genealogy tree here
and kind of break it down to you it's
completely it's completely fair enough
in your guys in your guys cases but
sometimes it's just interesting to
sometimes to get a sense of where
somebody's if somebody is from an
individual country because sometimes
that then colors there yeah that was
again and then honestly to context me
and that was an inside joke between us
because we're always like Russian girls
always cheat so that's what that's where
it was but we weren't saying to you in
Brazilian but I have
thank you babe the number the number one
cheaters
the number one the number one cheaters
the number one cheaters in South America
are the Colombians yeah
you know what I just realized oh my gosh
I grew up with nannies from around the
world so every year we had a different
Nanny from a different country
one married my cousin and she did cheat
on him and she was Russians
[Laughter]
from America right yeah yeah so she was
just wanted to get a Visa that's not
you're not talking about women
I just said all the all the nannies came
from these different countries who did
it I don't know she let the side down
I have nobody to cheat on I'm not
talking about you um I would would you
listen to your house do you listen to
your husband do you know what I think
friendship is about listening to each
other because you learn so much and I
think the reason we've done so well and
the way the kids have been turned out is
because we communicate a lot so my
specialty is in communication skills and
that was and no I when I came to the UK
I couldn't speak a word of English and
then slowly I met him I started
improving my English and now hopefully
everybody can understand me but it was
really really important for me to be
able to be understood and guys have you
noticed so why do you think people shout
at each other does anybody know the
answer besides the fact that they are
angry low IQ no because they feel their
hearts are part away so they feel like
so when you feel like you're far away
your hearts are far away you shot at
each other but when you're in love you
whisper you never say to somebody I love
you so do you listen to your husband yes
I have listened to him because I really
have needed his advice a lot in this
world okay so yeah of course he listens
to me I listen to him it's brilliant
okay so okay so that's what I'm asking
is it more traditional or is it more of
a partnership I don't know what it is
but I don't want to like if you guys
okay if you guys have a final decision
yeah so if if you want to do something
and he wants to do something and you
guys disagree you will not see each
other's side who makes the decision
I just think it's what's convenient okay
because we have the boys okay so you
switch off
oh I don't think I've ever had that
really I mean
okay a disagreement to that extent
you've never disagreed on anything
um not really I don't think we love that
okay that sounds great
communication as I say is key I'm sure
we have disagreed but soon you realize
what what's more important you have to
prioritize what's important for both I'm
just really asking if you are in more of
a traditional mindset where if you guys
disagree it's his decision or you
believe it's 50 50. that's my only
question
you guys switch off making decisions
he gets a job in another country you
don't want to go what happens well for
example when you got um when you wanted
to set up in Singapore I genuinely
didn't want to go because London is home
this is a safety net
and I said that I won't come but you go
and he thought that was crazy because he
didn't want to be without me and the
children
okay so so but then I followed his lead
because I realized that I didn't want to
be without him good one okay I'm gonna
give her a clap right now that's a good
woman that's a good woman no and
everybody needs to know this we should
see men as our allies and not as our
enemy and I am not one of this women
that wasn't here and point fingers at
man man completely
took away my innocence and absolutely
destroyed me but equally men are the
ones that picked me up and built up my
you know believe and trust in them so
we're not all bad yeah I never say
because there is bed in in every culture
in every religion in every gender so you
can't sit around and point fingers I
support men and I support anything
that's right so do what's right rather
than what's popular yeah and that and
that goes and and if I may add on to
that please that that goes on to the
sense of Duty you had a sense of Duty to
your husband you had a sense of Duty to
your children because you know that your
children love you your children also
love your husband yeah which is their
father and you said you know what I
don't want to go to Singapore however
my duties to this family yeah and I
don't want my kids without a father I
don't want my kids to be feeling
estranged yeah and so your feelings
didn't matter and you're like all right
let's go to Singapore yeah you can't be
selfish in a relationship if you're
selfish yeah you're just gonna crumble
selfish people selfish people end up
alone you end up by yourself in every
relationship I'm curious did any of your
friends tell you not to go your female
friends no actually no nobody okay so
they're all supported that's great
that's why she's still married but she's
got good friends around her she's got
good friends all of my friends are all
happily married I mean look it's awesome
you know they have found their Niche
within what they are trying to achieve
and it's experience it's alive because
it's very short I think one day in our
deathbed we're gonna look back and maybe
regret a lot of things and hopefully you
know
it's not leading the right person
I'm gonna take a second and read super
chats um so the Savvy ninja it's a
woman's duty to pick a man who shows
wisdom and his decision men it's on you
to continually grow in wisdom and good
decision making Leon I've been never
seen a grandmother 80 plus that looks
unhappy loved by her family playing a
meaningful life role in life Clarity in
what's expected of her day-to-day
reality it's simple and stable life all
is all that is gone Leon every
civilization since the dawn of human
time has been built on the stability of
marriage if women worked for if marriage
worked for our ancestors why are we
different promoting divorce is a divide
and conqueror scheme to implode Society
Doug MPA uh oh it's beard game gang
there's a 100 percent chance of simping
on the forecast today
it's gonna be raining
it's going to be more
um morale for all why not stop being
toxic
uh Let me refresh it real quick guys
wait till I'm done with the super chats
um guys make sure you like the video
that's the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these live
streams um how many let me look how many
likes we have in the chat right now
uh wait hold on I think I messed up the
page we're at 412 likes we need a
thousand more likes and we will open up
the chat okay so I'm gonna tell you guys
my opinion I think a divorce should be
banished
banished I think we should erase divorce
do you know what country it's illegal in
I think before we do it we should give
all the married people to be like look
here's your chance legally now to get
out of here yeah
they didn't sign up for that they
thought they're at the easy divorce yeah
so now anyone going forward knows if you
sign up for this contract you are stuck
for life because there's a lot of people
that really don't believe in divorce and
there are a lot of good women that want
to get married and stay married but the
men are like well
my friend married a good woman who
wanted to get married and stay married
and she divorced him and took half so
why should I trust you well I think the
government should force us to stay I
disagree yeah yeah so unless wait wait
wait wait I need you to yeah unless
there's three reasons
yeah
okay addiction abuse and adultery
and I still think
try to be separated first and then try
to work it out yeah because there are
success success stories of people that
have gotten through abuse addiction and
adultery we never talk about those and I
think first you should put the kids
first so that's my yeah if it's first
100 and what you disagree no no I agree
I didn't know you was going to say that
but but I was also going to say that if
if a woman's hitting a man I don't think
that should be because you should be
good for divorce if your woman's hitting
here like man up bro like oh you like it
is
if you're a grown man and your woman
seen you like come on bro boss up man
like you can't get divorced This Woman's
hitting you like I don't agree that you
should be hearing you slip encounter
yeah
I also don't know this this is going to
be controversial but I also don't think
a woman should divorce the man if he
cheats as well I think if a woman cheats
that's far more
yeah I think cheating for a woman is a
hundred times completely different than
cheating for a man
women could disagree when a woman cheats
she's trying to replace you when a man
cheats you she's just there a woman want
to sleep with somebody let me tell you
something about let me tell you
something when a guy when a guy cheats
on a girl
nine times out of ten when he cheats on
her
there's some flaws and the woman he's
cheating with that his main girl has
that this one doesn't have and that
actually makes him like his main girl
more that's it's a that's a
controversial idea I think he's actually
flaws though would you just think he
fancies like a bit of variety I mean
like because you know the classic thing
you know you can have you can have steak
at home but you just sometimes fancy a
McDonald's no no you do fancy McDonald's
but sometimes there's like a homeless
person in the park you're doing a lot of
McDonald's that you don't want to deal
with McDonald's do I no no but like what
I'm trying to say is that typically when
a guy does cheat
he doesn't leave for that one because
the main woman and listen to him from a
man's perspective
when he cheats okay
the main girl actually gains more value
because he he is he decides this he's
just satisfying she's just a pleb she's
just there for pleasure pump and dump
sayonara and then the main girl has
what he wants for the long term and a
lot of people it's an uncomfortable
conversation to have right but hold on
hold on
just listen let me just let me make my
point let me make my point right
a lot of guys when they do do that they
actually appreciate the mean girl more
and I know you don't want to hear that
but that's a that's a reality
this is what it is an opinion by nature
men we can all get over that over the
hills but the facts are by an age I mean
a polygamous by Nature women are not so
having said that the thing is women
especially in the west they're not
having it they're saying he's having me
or nothing so men are trying to fight
their natural urges it's basically like
a man saying to a woman when you when
you're on your period or when you're
pregnant and your hormones are going all
over the place I don't want to hear you
crying I don't want to see you cry don't
kick off at me how unfair would that be
to the woman so you'd imagine a man
saying to a woman
shut up don't cry don't be emotional
don't get argue with me but when a man's
got hormones I'm react to them then it's
a completely different thing cheating
you mean
no no no no no no I'm saying is when you
have hormones and a man has hormones
you're allowed to because it's illness
God made us like this God Made Men
polygamous by Nature so you're telling
me but where did you get that
information
listen listen okay you're basically
using the information for you no no no
no no
listening
if a month it can be absolutely in love
with his woman ready to die for it do
anything for us don't sleep with someone
I think the fun of it if a woman's in
love with a man she um the best looking
man in the world could come to show a
Repose invisible yeah it's invisible but
a man could be absolutely be started
with a woman to go [__] ugly [__]
because it just is not the same listen
listen also they surveyed cheaters they
survey cheaters the majority of cheating
is only one time so women are throwing
away marriages for a one-time thing yeah
and then listen someone else there's a
book called sex by Dawn as well right
and it talked and it talks about even
the shape of male penis you've seen a
penis before right I'm sure no okay
you're a virgin too uh but the structure
of the penis too is meant to push his
sperm in and then you know the outside
mushroom The Edge is to pull other man's
sperm out right because that's how we
are set up biologically speaking it's in
the book I just told you the book sex at
dawn who wrote the book Dr Christopher
okay
Dr Christopher if we're going to go from
a biological perspective like men would
only pass on DNA when they impregnated
like the most women a lot of kids used
to die during childbirth no but what up
sorry doctor for Christopher Dr
Christopher Ryan what about sperm Wars
though is that in spur is that these
doctors come up with horses
do you know what's interesting though
it's like if a guy fulfills his mating
strategy which is like impregnating as
many women as possible he's shamed and
like they're often said that's a bad
thing but if a woman fulfills her mating
strategy by getting the best guy she
possibly can like the richest tallest
most handsome that's just considered
normal yeah I had to express really well
the other day by somebody on one of
these shows uh she said when men cheat
it's just like they cheat when women
cheat they mean it and that's the
problem and that's the problem isn't it
a woman will never sleep with someone
that she doesn't like and if she's in
love with her husband she will she it's
impossible for a woman to teach she's in
love with us but unless she's
fundamentally broken Patrice O'Neill
said it best
cheating is for women it's benefit
I think I was completely against the
sanctity of marriage there are vows I'm
being facetious obviously
so for show of hands who here would work
through addiction with their partner so
their partner is addicted to something
if there was a possible outcome of her
recovering there's no possible she's
going back if she shared it with me okay
pass the dutchie
who here would work out adultery with
their partner so their partner cheats on
them any guy puts up their hands we're
fighting why will I will work it out
everybody deserves interesting
I figured Daniel said he's 50 50.
who would who would try to work out
abuse with their partner if they felt
like they had a part to play I shall
endure
I shallot I shall endure
sorry can you repeat the question I said
who would work out work through abuse
with their partner if they felt like
they had a party
yeah of course you've got to recognize
if you've done something so it's hard to
play yeah yeah yeah okay okay so um the
thing I think with this conversation the
reason I always gets like like this
right is because I don't know guys have
a really hard it's very hard for guys to
explain what they mean do you know what
it is in a woman's way to a woman you
know what I mean so when a guy says oh
it went like oh guys cheat for different
reasons and girls and guys will do it
before what a girl a lot of times
because I saw you being with the faces
and stuff what they're hearing is you've
given a pause or you being like Oh it's
okay for one person that's not okay but
that's not the conversation we're having
we're talking we're not talking about
the outcome we're talking about the
reason for the outcome that's a kind
conversation that the guys are having
the reason that this happens is
different it triggers an emotional
response in you because you think they
were saying men should cheat
like you're giving yourself a pause
because we have this because we were
supposed
men try so hard to understand us but we
never try to understand man look so a
lot of times so a lot of times when men
are trying to explain how they are to us
we get this gut reaction we get mad when
they're just explaining that cheating is
different for men and for women it's not
the same I totally agree it is different
but it doesn't justify the one for them
so no but no no have to say I'd like to
clarify that I don't I don't cheat at
all I was gonna actually wait for a
break and then I was gonna say exactly
yeah I need to clarify I don't agree
with chin men should not cheat
God knows it's our natural needs nobody
should cheating
but the difference is like men can love
a girl and cheat on her yeah yes there's
no emotional investment yeah because if
I was there she's available
I would rather have my man to say okay
can we do something together
and I say Let's go people have got your
back you know but it's this backstabbing
that it's a backstabbing that hurts
because it's same as you do to your best
friend or whatever when you do something
behind someone's back that's what's hurt
can I ask you a question
for her it really adds to the context
would you have had that same stance 10
years ago when you were 24
um no but no no because I was much
younger and don't forget I was at a time
where for basically two years my fiance
was in the box and I he said I I'm not
attacking her insulting no no I'm just
sharing he said I'll retract my you know
proposal because I don't want you to be
a widow so young and I said no I'm gonna
be there for you two years I flew from
London to Geneva while starting my
bachelor's wearing that so they have a
mask the hat everything I couldn't touch
him I couldn't kiss him but I was there
I wasn't going anywhere and uh you know
so I believe in the fact that I will
support my man but my man will also
support me because as much as I respect
him he will respect me I want to add on
to something so then at 24 that would
have been a hard no but now at 34 you're
negotiable like okay if you're gonna
cheat cheat with me no because now my
I'm a bit more open-minded like I'm I'm
thinking but I haven't tried this people
talk okay because now we live in a very
different world I hear things that I've
never done before I've never seen I
don't know what it is so I was thinking
okay if I would ever try something would
be with my man because he deserves
anything he wants you know give me your
Instagram after the show
is a woman being bisexual is that a plus
for you sometimes
there's only room for one degenerate in
this relationship and that's me so in a
wife is that is that a plus no no no no
no for me no no it's it's it's it's sane
as cheating so I was in a relationship I
was in love before I was married I was
in love and
um we were out all night I had some
friends home
and was it after party just chilling out
I went to bed and uh my girlfriend at
the time was just hanging out with some
friends and then she wandered in with a
girl I was just I was just half asleep
looked up and they just sat on top of
the bed and they started kissing
and I was so upset her um
the crazy thing is I look back I look
back like oh my God I missed such fun
you know I could have so much fun there
but in the moment if I'm in love with
her she's cheating doesn't matter who it
is and I couldn't do it did you think
you were going to be into it and did you
freak out yeah I said what get get the
hell out of it oh yeah
marriage so um do you want to pull up
the video This is called the transformed
wife for anyone who wants to you know
follower on YouTube
because she's age oh damn that was from
a woman that was from a woman just
starting it out there female sexual
competition coming
I think she's been married for a long
time how would you open
out there even among Christians
that our husbands are supposed to meet
our emotional needs now you can't find
that scripturally
there to be our spiritual leaders there
to wash us with the word and if we have
a question at church we're to ask them
at home
so there definitely are spiritual
leaders they're head over us we're to
submit to their leadership they aren't
authority over us there to protect us
and they're to nourish and cherish us as
Ephesians 5 says
and they are to provide for us if any
man does not provide for his family he's
worse than an infidel
but none of these verses there's no
verse in the Bible that says that our
husbands are supposed to meet our
emotional needs what are they even you
know to me or that's such a
that's not something you can grab a hold
of you can grab a hold of being the
spiritual leader you know watching us
with the word reading the word to us
rebuking us teaching us we can Define
what providing for us me means meeting
our physical
needs our need for clothing and for food
and shelter
you can Define what protection means to
to protect us from harm and injury or
when we're injured they'll help us but
you can't really clearly Define what our
emotional needs are
and
this is why in fact I just studied
yesterday I wrote a post about it
yesterday I'll link it below but the
term emotional needs didn't even come
into existence until the 80s and it was
pop psychology and it caused us to look
Inward and think about us and what we
need and Define what our emotional needs
we all get to Define what our emotional
needs are we don't Define those other
needs the spiritual the being protected
the being provided for this you know our
husbands being our spiritual
leader those are defined in scripture
but our emotional needs we get to Define
what those are and so they become what
this article said is it's narcissist
it's thinking about ourselves and what
we want yes we were created emotional
beings we cry we laugh we agree we mourn
we praise the Lord you know but
God tells us over and over again that we
are to be joyful and thankful to take
every thought captive to The Obedience
of Christ to remove new our minds with
God's word all of our emotions come from
our thoughts
and we alone are the only ones who
control our thoughts I used to use my
emotions continually in the early years
of my marriage to manipulate my husband
and it was ugly you know and women will
use their emotions all the time too many
the others we use our emotions after and
before we're going to start our period
and and we get in bad moods and we're
sour and we're we can justify that
because we're going to start our period
or when we're sick and I had to learn
when I was sick for many years that just
because I was miserable I wasn't going
to make other people miserable there's
no way my husband could have met all of
my emotional needs
of Despair and and pain and suffering
and almost falling into a bit of this
depression when I was so ill for so many
years I had to learn to take my thoughts
continually captive to The Obedience of
Christ I went to renew my Minds women
it's your job to be in control of your
emotions
so is your husband supposed to meet your
emotional needs
she's right she makes it she makes a
really good point doesn't she because
this is kind of what I was less
articulately trying to say in the sense
that we emotional needs is a very
nebulous term right what does it
actually mean you know it's hard to grab
hold of right like she says but the
problem is that marriage is now
predicated on that so A woman will say
well he didn't meet my emotional needs
so therefore I'm gonna divorce him and
I'm gonna go and travel the Caribbean
for five years and you know find myself
whatever but it's like it's an
ever-shifting thing isn't it emotional
needs it can change on the on the you
know the on the turn of a coin really
and um that's that that's the problem
that we have in marriage today and
certainly in formalizing marriage into a
into a contract and trying to blind
people with that contract when it's
based in Emotion which is which is
changeable I mean if you are gonna base
your life your business your diet
program whatever on emotionalism you're
gonna fail like imagine if you Google
and you're like hey like what is the
capital of India and it's like sorry we
don't feel like answering that right now
would Google be the number one search
provider in the world no right if you're
gonna base your life upon how you feel
it is an absolute guarantee that you are
going to be a failure but this is where
there's always a question I feel between
men and women because women are by
nature and it's the beauty of them
they're emotional creatures We're Men
are very logical and I feel like
sometimes you have to understand and
have patience with each other and
understand because sometimes this this
is the like women will say
um I just need a man that understands me
yeah I need a man that's understanding
but then but then they don't even
understand ourselves
they'll be in the mood I won't tell you
why and they just expect you to know
about what Geniuses but that's the
beauty of women we have the relationship
to find themselves
why do you have to find yourself and how
many times men yeah we've been in a
relationship and your misses will come
back and she's got she's modest she's
not speaking what's up no nothing yeah
yeah you want me to be understanding I
wish I will and they they get angry I
was like why why do we not understand
them but we're very easy to understand
were the most planes straight down the
line okay I'm upset about this women
they don't but that's the beauty of them
men and women are different silent
treatment doesn't doesn't that link to
like a boredom Theory so I heard this
Theory right and stick with me this
might be this might be a little
long-winded thing so important theory
that I saw online is essentially saying
that we now live in a world right that
all the essential things that needed to
be done are done so people are now so
bored with reality that they are finding
things to argue about think about like
this in medieval times when they have to
worry about famine and where their war
is coming from women's rights and
emotional back and emotion and the
husbands being the emotional Rock was
never a thing yeah back when back in
um Mongolian days when all these guys
are doing it the emotional needs of a
marriage was never brought up but it is
now why is it different now to back then
what is different the thing that is
different now is now human races go
most of that [__] in order and now it's
about feelings it's not about Duty
that's what I'm saying it's better if
you feel like and that's a
western-centric problem you know like if
you're just about to say this if you
look at the East okay India divorce rate
one percent Vietnam divorce rate does
anybody know the divorce rate in Vietnam
no no seven percent or not okay you look
at all the Philippines divorce do you
guys know divorce rate in Philippines
it's very low my fiance is Filipinos is
zero because it's illegal
[Laughter]
guess what else is illegal and you'll be
very happy about this
abortions
Pearl's moving to Manila
[Laughter]
you know what on that same point you I
was literally um it struck a chord with
me because I've just come back from
Gambia I was out there doing some
charity work and these lot I've got
nothing yeah and you see what within
themselves oh it's so hard yeah and I
just and I was actually thinking the
same thing I was thinking
have the same like they're not gonna
have the same um
but like emotional desires like all the
issues that we have because I'm thinking
they literally are some they're survival
they're on survival like they're walking
miles to get water they're trying to
find out what they're trying to ration
the rice and this and that and I just
even the way they are now I see the
Dynamics between the men and the women
and they all get along all the children
play together and they're literally just
live in mud Huts in the middle of a
desert I scored in hot and I think
no one nobody no two humans are going to
get on completely fine all the time but
I just think I better divorce or
split-ups never even they're too worried
about trying to raise their kids don't
die yeah because in the west we're two
we're two sort of fat aren't we we're
too lazy and we're too we're too
comfortable yeah and so now we've got
all these other issues these are the
problems
fake problems we're like oh you know
what God I'm such a loser I only have an
iPhone 13.
we live in a privileged society that
we're not even aware of anymore we're
very privileged it's good to go one day
it's good to go out to them Federal
countries and literally you come back so
grateful and you come back and just
think my problems are actually nothing
I'm bothered because I don't got Wi-Fi
my Wi-Fi is not working that happened to
me when I was I happened I was lucky
enough for that happened to me when I
was 15. I went to Johannesburg South
Africa my mom helped me raise money to
go on this missions trip with my church
and I went out to like the boonies of I
think we were in krugersdorp which is
another city in South Africa and I met a
lady who had gangrene in her leg and we
went to her house which was like dirt
floor and like tin Shack and we prayed
for her we're like Lord please deliver
this woman from her gangrene and then I
was foolish young boy 15 I was like
Lord's gonna cure her right like she's
gonna be okay right but later they told
me like most likely This Woman's gonna
die and then I went back to my area
where I lived where I lived on the
outskirts of the rich white area and I
could go to the school I went to Winter
Park High School which was like one of
the richest high schools in Florida and
I would see people be like oh you know
my dad sucks he bought me a used Honda
Civic and I wanted a BMW you know this
air conditioning sucks it only makes me
Kinda hot and I was like in Africa
Watching Death happen in a hopeless
situation your perspective is totally
changed and I'm so grateful that my mom
was able to pay for that and that I was
able to get that perspective on life
because you know in the West were so
just drunk on the benefits yeah like
like the quite frankly like the the
glory are not working the glory of War
for for that our our ancestors won when
they you know storm Normandy and you
know and endured all these attacks from
the Japanese and whatnot so I just think
about everything pulling back to where
we are right now I just think that our
lives are so good that we have to make
problems yeah when you think about a lot
of the culture War stuff it's based on
that is it like a lot of these cultures
yes so take it home of you guys the
boredom theory is real guys
I want to read you about um this is the
column where they answer some of the
real problems that we have today in
marriage okay now I I don't want you
guys to take this lightly I want to
pretend like we are answering This
Woman's question okay
dear
Jessica that's the girl's name my
husband wakes me up in the middle of the
night wanting sex
I struggle to fall back asleep
afterwards and have told him so I wake
up very early for work each day so the
fact that he continues to awaken me
troubles me because I am not getting
adequate sleep when I bring this up he
claims I wake him up and that he is
trying to satisfy me I feel like he's
gaslighting me but he and continues to
insist it is my doing how do I help
now I want to First give you guys
what this woman said to her now we'll
see do women give good relationship
advice no just okay well no maybe let's
let's give her the benefit of the doubt
yeah she's like it's a waste of time all
right look look good it's possible your
husband is lying to you
to justify to justify his habit of of
waking you for sex and it's also
possible possible you're experiencing
some form of what it what is known as
sex insomnia
get one of those little surveillance
cameras that record the movements
just gonna say just do it
exactly I wish I had that problem only
because only because the camera is only
to do one thing is to underline who is
the actual culprit because she said that
he said it's her she said she said it's
him so you get the camera out and you
prove who did it yeah but what are you
just not what are you just not
complaining just do it yeah
what's gonna happen so they get the
camera and they're like aha he's doing
it then what yeah
I want to give up I want to give a
proper shout out to our friend Ali Real
Fem Sapien she gave a really good book
that I think a lot of women and men
should read it's the proper care and
feeding of husbands by Dr Lauren
Schlesinger has anybody read that book
no I think you're on commission or
something how many books have you
mentioned I read a lot no verse um so do
we
um so you know that's a really good book
for women to understand like what men
really want and Dr Lawrence she does a
really really really good job at it but
maybe that wouldn't be an issue if she
was being fulfilled each time
[Music]
she's been woken up and not you know
he's like cheers you know and she's like
what the hell we just started maybe she
said for a week maybe she said it keeps
her awake after she never said that it
was bad she said like so maybe it's Ross
in it and then maybe he's thinking you
know what it's a good session I can go
back to sleep there because no because
women do wake up once you've had sex I
just said I thought it was your duty to
have sex with your husband so obviously
yeah like marriage is an exclusive
sexual contract If you deny your partner
sex like who is he supposed to go get it
from
yeah but even in the military you're not
always on duty you're only on duty on
certain time like no you're always on
duty
like say if you are the horse guard
you're great you only I'm due to while
you're standing
now
you get to be a wife when you feel like
it yeah what I'm trying to say is you
always use these negative words and
negative connotation like for me this is
this is part like what was negative
about doing your duties because for me
that's not a duty it's a pleasure it's
not a job
what if I wanted to find pleasure what
if I wanted to find pleasure with
another woman
so then you're on duty
so then you're on duty so he's
he's sleeping with another girl but the
girls
wait but the girl is not weak for not
sleeping with her husband let's get
let's get real I'm sorry but I really
need to put an end to to this like oh
what should we do we should do whatever
we want in the end no you shouldn't do
whatever you want that is complete
that's the selfish nature that's gonna
get your ass alone and dying with the
dog did he get you recently I hear but
listen let me just uh go don't look at
me I'm just saying like you you you're
bringing you know to me and like oh
shouldn't be doing wait wait what get me
or what
okay let's just go back no no back up
your statement
I'm not gonna even go into this okay
fair play but you brought it up I know
yeah
you're insulting him personally when he
didn't insult I didn't mean to insult
him that probably came out wrong but you
can't say that it's okay I have this
effect on women on podcasts I have this
effect maybe I'm afraid you know but I I
you can't go immediately use that or
I'll go sleep with somebody you have to
respect that we are not machines women
are not machine it's a must no no I I
didn't I didn't say you're a machine but
his point was that she said it's about
pleasure and so he's saying if it's
about pleasure yeah I didn't I didn't
listen with my men
no no no no no no no not on the clock or
off the clock let me add some contacts
let me let me add some contacts what I'm
trying to say let me add some context to
the statement that I made I didn't say
my wife was neglecting me sexually but
you don't because just listen again
allow me to finish my sentence sure and
add some context to this theoretical
this situation we're talking right now I
was saying because you mentioned it was
about pleasure I said so what if another
woman were to offer me pleasure outside
of the relationship but I mean you
always bring in other women let's bring
in let's do it
can I can I say something in her support
no let's go there's only one Queen same
way for me there is only one king and
that means
but Kings throughout history have always
had concubines if we're gonna go back I
don't care who has what I am this I am
in like I know you my analogy seemed to
be funny for you but my analogy they fit
into what I am the analogy is not funny
but I mean this is the Andrew tight
argument isn't it where the wife is the
the kid the head woman she is like she
is my queen she is the she is the queen
absolutely but that doesn't mean that he
won't necessarily
on occasion entertain which is fine but
my he would never be my man that that's
the only thing
I I don't need to give anyone advice
what you're saying is like it's about my
pleasure and it's all about me that's
not what I said wait yes you just said
it's about pleasure this is just
twisting now
if you are married you can make all the
comments in the world if you're not in a
marriage just assuming that's how it
should be yeah yeah
they're response to that to that
scenario is this they should just
compromise if if it's an issue if it's
that much of an issue for her then she
said don't wake me up in the middle of
the night but yeah I'll wake you up in
the right way yeah yeah
I just agree I really think sex is a
duty I think you're supposed to listen
to your husband
thank you thank you oh my God
I got to see it live where's the camera
send a super chat right now so we give
that kick out cam whoa whoa whoa what's
happening because the thing is I'm
engaged so I'm not allowed to talk about
it yeah no but this is the thing it's
like when women don't like it's so
feminine it's like when women don't like
what you have to say they'll attack you
personally and she started to do it to
you she does it to me but it's like is
what we're saying true or is it not true
to bring the Sephora woman hates my
message the more I know I'm on the right
path the thing where you you took it
away from reality because the the
original discussion was about being
woken at the middle of the night nobody
can deal with sleep depravity very well
I was woken up last night by a woman who
wanted to have sex with me and I didn't
want to have sex
I was enduring last night no no I was
literally enduring the last time
it's a persistent complain because she's
a nice girl I keep getting woken up
every night I am not going to be with
that person for very long that's the
reality of the conversation but what's
Johnson so John you're saying that you
were with a woman last night and you
didn't particularly feel like putting it
out but for the team you endured I
didn't want her to make a headpiece on
me I'm like
you know what I think I can see if on
both sides of the coin I think if if
I've never been in a relationship where
I've Ever Wanted sex or not I've been
refused that's um this does never happen
so I can't really relate but I can
imagine how frustrating it would be I
think if but I also agree if you're if
she's asleep and you're waiting for her
to go to sleep then waking up for sex
that can't be nice for over a long
period of time if it's someone off here
and there yeah you should do it but I
just think if you're waiting for it to
go to sleep I think they can be
compromised I think if you love her you
would and you respect her you don't have
to just think oh well that's when I
wanted is compromise but also if she's
asleep and you need it sometimes wake up
yeah yo but but I think my point is the
mindset it's not even about the action
it's like you're supposed to have a
selfless mindset in marriage it's not
supposed to be about you yeah yeah that
was my point when they were talking it
was always about them it's about my
pleasure yeah no I agree don't confuse
it please what I said about pleasure
don't confuse it please don't I know
it's easy to point fingers and say
that's what you think but let me just
clear clarify it again what I said about
pleasure is you said you also said I'm
not on the clock 24 7. so that's me yes
so I'm talking about Duty for me duty is
a negative connotation where it's
pleasure my man's pleasure for me is a
positive pronunciation
give me a chance to explain so you say
you're looking at the same coin from a
different but one sounds a little bit
uncomfortable whereas the other one
makes you know it feels like I I would
always pleasure my man I don't need to
have a duty not to pleasure my man
I'd rather call it volunteering work you
know I I understand what you're saying
those two sounds very different I get
you but if a burglar breaks into the
house it's not my pleasure to go and
defend my family it's my duty to go and
defend my family yes but that's
different you're talking about burglar
I'm talking about my husband it's not
it's not a burglar no I think it's the
same thing because he's talking about
when he has to do something he doesn't
want to do and we're talking about it's
different this is a protect
is even more if you want to rank it
right when someone's burglaring your
house he's risking the ultimate asset
his life to protect your life
yeah but we slide we you were talking
about someone waking you up in the
middle of the night to have some fun
times and now then all of a sudden you
ended up in a place where someone is
coming to attack us yeah
for me I would rather have a you know I
like I understand what you mean and it's
Duty in a sense but to see your whole
marriage as a woman or as a man as a
duty I understand why people don't want
to get married you should have sex every
night how would you react if he said no
to sex for you
I mean I would respect it but he cannot
say no to me too often that's tough
you're gonna go go home get the [__] out
of here get out of here
so listen why why is this happening
across the globe why is this happening
on the whatever podcast why is this
happening on fresh and fit and why is it
happening on the pregame what the [__]
is going on here come on guys but I also
wanted to make it
all right why I've been on all three of
these shows on three different corners
of the earth why is this happening it's
just
okay wait also wait wait wait no
um so fan mattress said modern women
have lost leverage they are just not
aware of the fact thank you for the 200
Super Chat well that's a big one two
hundo send 500 or we'll block Canal
yeah yes we'll just block her from the
show
oh yes oh yeah yeah guys guys
um that's ten percent of the way 100 100
bucks we'll mute a mic for five minutes
[Music]
oh no yeah okay
um let me I'm gonna read the rest of the
super chats though one second guys make
sure you like the video a like is the
most important metric that YouTube uses
to push out these live streams also guys
um make sure that you guys are leaving a
comment and let me know
um let me know if you guys thought that
girl was a virgin yesterday yes or one
in the chat if you did okay Rob um
bordocks Dr Laura's book is great
pickle Rick for the ladies and gentlemen
do you have conversations about men and
women in an honest capacity with friends
and family members if you do do you
trust those that those you have these
conversations with her being honest just
raise the hands really quick who has
conversations about these kind of topics
with their family and their friends
friends yes yeah my mom's texting me
right now
my Nan's loving this
herb and cut her off she's for the
streets and give her what she wants the
streets Zoo Notch make a poll about this
those questions night shift 1000 I
disagree with what they are saying if
you love your girl be loyal to her even
if she's not don't stoop to her level
even if she's not it doesn't mean that
through me is it well yeah don't stoop
your level be better man send that money
back
[Laughter]
it's a woman's duty to pick a man who
showed Oh I read that one let me just
refresh it really quick to make sure
also guys uh make sure you send them to
our Google form so you can be informed
when we have events in London
um Gerardo when people love each other
the sex will be frequent it won't even
be a logical debate the issue is like
the woman about how it is explained I've
actually heard guys that when a woman
has like a child it stops because she
gets more her like depends it depends
what the person means by by love right I
mean yeah they might still be fond of
the person but if the if the
attraction's gone the sports God the sex
is not going to be frequent and when a
woman has a child everything in her
entire life gets shifted to a number two
priority because the children are number
one indeed I have one thing that can
debunk that entire thing your parents do
they have more sex when they after they
had you or less I don't want to talk
about that I don't want to talk about
that I didn't ask them because it's like
that that point that they make that
point that they made is that oh if you
love your partner but it's like every
relationship that I've ever seen go past
like 15 years they all say the same
thing it should be 15 years 15. I mean
like oh so it's like you're not
listening to the people in long-term
relationships or you just don't want you
aren't talking to them because everyone
in long-term relationships all say the
same thing the sex goes up and down a
lot yeah they're usually gone after a
while it like the attraction comes in
waves absolutely it comes in waves and
you're like sometimes your girl she like
looks good and listen in in life
sometimes you gain weight you get a
little fat sometimes you lose weight
sometimes your skin breaks out right
life happens we need to stop demanding
perfection in relationships when we're
all broken and perfect people
to answer your point earlier because I
was trying to I was trying to interject
but everyone was just arguing someone
will kick Taro it's crazy
right so to to that point that was made
with the story with the guy and go yes
there's a few things that I would
personally need I need to know the facts
of the story which is why I wanted the
camera because we all know that people
like to when they retell stories they
tell themselves to be the protagonist of
those stories so I'd like like some sort
of information that will let me know
what the actual facts are right that's
number one number two right when it
comes when it is my it's it's my it's my
pleasure and blah blah blah blah it's
like all right so I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm
I'm a fiance as well and I've seen these
marriages and stuff like how if if we're
playing the whole I don't want to do it
right now so I'm not going to do it I
think that's a very very slippery slope
it's a [__] because what if the bill
comes the restaurant like listen baby I
don't feel like I don't feel like I feel
like you know it's time for you to whip
out that [__] Discover Card someone
someone attacks you on the street he's
like you know what today I just don't
feel like protecting
like like what Ty was saying too like
okay listen baby the last mugger I
whooped his ass like listen here's the
night here's the knife I taught you the
shank moves like get out there and be
someone honey go go out there go for the
neck take them out go ahead I don't want
to be uh I don't want to be a chauvinist
Pig the reason I bring this point up is
because we all agree that our a
relationship is a partnership that has
both sides I have to give a certain
amount to it to make it work right right
if we agree on that how can we then
disagree on the fact that this is what
that guy needs for it to work and he
kind of might need that yeah it might be
a disadvantage to you but if I was to
talk about all the times I did stuff for
my partner that I didn't want to do at
the time and we start playing tallies
right this is one of those things where
um what was it cancel this man he's
making too much sense no when you're in
a relationship when your relationship it
was one thing that I saw when you bring
to you you should do this you should go
on the on the street find a couple right
and then ask the ask the girl how many
things do you ask of your man to do in a
day-to-day basis then ask the guy the
same question more times than not the
woman has asked the guy to do at least
five times more than he's asked from her
in a day-to-day like like basis you know
yeah well that's why I keep going back
to the mindset like the my like the
mindset in a marriage is supposed to be
to give it's not to receive it's like
what can I do for the other person in
traditional marriages anyway but the
problem is the intimate nature of the
sexual act that's why there's you know I
I imagine that there's some sort of
consternation around this point but but
but the problem is that you've got due
to a living in sexist marriages for
decades all right and I mean is that
really what they signed up for you know
is that is that a workable way to to
conduct a relationship it works the
other way as well I know women in
marriages that they don't get enough yes
yeah come on I say pleasure and you
attack me with the no I wasn't thinking
about robberies and then she says give
but no we know sometimes the point you
have to take it to extreme what I'm
saying is maybe I'm not using the right
words but you continuously think that I
don't understand you but actually I
think you don't understand me okay I'm
saying about the pleasure is giving is
pleasure to my men so you just said it
yourself giving marriage should be about
giving and I'm saying for me way be
woken up or wake up my man is pleasure
because I am giving so actually we're
saying exactly the same thing using the
different words
but it's not a duty I don't want to see
it as a duty I don't want to feel like
I'm going to work you know I want to
feel like I'm at home because it's my
home I feel at home I can do this
anytime I want so what about my points
but then that doesn't mean I want her to
answer this so what about my point what
was your point sorry what was it exactly
those guys and I I purposely took this
time to make sure that the my argument
isn't the same as that I wasn't talking
about do you I was talking about my
whole thing was can you if we were to
take a list of all the times that they
were probably okay I remember how many
and that he that you've asked of them
and they didn't want to do it and if
we're going to be very paid right this
is a very Petty thing to do I'm not
saying to go out and make this list
right but it's one of those things that
like sometimes needs to be made because
like visual understanding sometimes is
the best teacher to see an actual graph
of the amount of times you ask him for
something in a day-to-day week to week
month to month and the amount of times
that he asks you puts into perspective
how much you ask from your from a
significant other on a regular basis
right if if the only thing that he's
asking for because he's he's gone to
work and he's come back and he's coming
back late and he wants he wants to have
sex if that's all he's asking for I'm
not saying it's great he probably should
not wake you up in the middle of the
night that's not that's not good jokes
right but but we're acting like it's
it's like it's like I can't believe he's
asked for this thing from me when it's
like bro how many times how many times I
think you're saying she's saying like I
don't want to have to yeah exactly but
I'm gonna do it it's not a problem for
me yeah but men don't want to have men
don't want to have to eyeballs but their
point is there's all these things that
men do like all the time for women that
they that they just they don't want to
do but they have to do so there's
literally nobody like nobody's attacking
you we're just yeah yeah I cannot answer
for all the women what I'm saying is I'm
in solidarity with you yeah
but uh I'm not able to answer for all
those women that you are talking about
to be honest because I can only talk
from my own perspective
um so I have another question
um if men pursue if men pursue and
propose and marry women
would that mean that they have to endure
more because they made the choice to
marry and invest in a woman
America's woman didn't have to agree to
marry him so I think you both have a
well in marriage you both have a duty so
yeah you both have to the the the the
there's a level of Endurance on both
sides I feel like men definitely are
better at enduring because as we can see
from the statute women leave far greater
number of the time and initiate the boss
far greater than mendu so men but men
have to go to war every day we have to
go to war every day so we're we're
enjoying stuff just trying to keep food
on the family for our table this right
ways of black everyone's trying to make
the same everyone's trying to make a lot
of money everyone's trying to provide
and we're just going to war every day so
we're used to enjoying women well they
see it or not some women don't get me
wrong I'm not I'm I'm speaking in
general terms some women have to go out
and get the bag they've not got a man
and they probably didn't some of them
have another dad in their life they've
not got a man so they have to go and get
the bread also I'm talking in general
terms men are used to enjoying so I feel
like women they live as a whole they
live a softer life when it comes to
going out taking the stresses of Life
men are better at dealing with stress
what we're built foreign
but on the flip side is don't
underestimate or downplay how much of a
great and a hard role it is for a woman
to raise a family like they raise
children like it women are actually I
look at women and I actually just think
I don't know how you do this women's
Beauty they can raise a family they've
got cooked they'll cook they'll raise
the kids have got three kids that do
real multiple jobs that's the beauty of
a woman
what percent of women actually raise
their kids
and the state doesn't or the daycare
doesn't see this is say I don't know the
stats but this is what I love a woman
that I'm I'm a provider used to home and
raise the kids that's what I think
because I think a lot of the time they
go to Nursery to do this I think if
you're both struggling to pay the bills
then you have to think okay look we have
to the most important thing is keeping
the kids alive and healthy but I think
if you're in a situation I don't I me
personally I don't like if the man can
afford to pay all the bills on this and
she still choose to work why are you
going to work now spend less time with
the kids just because you want a better
Gucci bag or something stay at home
raise the kids and that's your beauty
that's your job and I'll go out there
and conquer the water make sure I come
back with food to partner tape because
it's sad I see this a lot and and even
um me trying to date as I've got older a
lot of the sticking point is women don't
want to stay at home they want to go out
and they want to be independent so I'm
like so who's going to look after the
kids and they're like yeah they can go
today again I don't want to only tweeze
the kids I don't want the state toys the
kids that our kids you you raise them
and I'll help you obviously I'm going to
come back but my job is I manage to go
home and bring the bacon yeah
my thing is if women want to be equal
then be equal split the
like half the time you know but it's
like they just want equality yeah but
it's not real equality pay on half pay
half the bills be equal the best
relationships I found is when a man
knows his role in a relationship and a
woman men and women are equal but
they're different I'm not gonna people
say oh men men and women ain't equal the
women equal they're different we're all
human beings but they're not the same
let's not act like they're the same and
the problem is this is another thing I
hear and I spoke about this not long ago
women
like I have to take on a muscular
because one of my pets one of my biggest
sixes masculine women I can't it's one
of my biggest turnouts but they're like
we have to act masculine because we
haven't got a man so we have to do it
ourselves I'm like all right cool I've
not got a woman does that mean act like
a woman
why do you have to take you can still be
a woman and get a job you can still have
a job and be a feminine and be a woman
you don't have to be this old boss [__]
I could do this because men when men get
money for me personally and I know a lot
of men when they go to work and they're
grinding and they're going out and
they're stressing to get the monies for
this they think of all the stuff they
can do and provide their family but when
women get the money they think about the
stuff that all the reasons they don't
need a man now to get it they get rich
and think I don't need a man I'm
independent where I might get switched
to think so I can't wait to raise a
family look like it I've got this money
and I can raise my own family and that's
the difference between this new age
woman that just and they're always
unhappy I imagine being 40 years old
with no kids what a vapious horrible
boring life you've got no kids to run
around you just sat there with her I
think
that's a crazy thing
I saw your eyes
an inside joke listen he because he's 40
what it's not about you relax we we've
been friends for many years this is not
about you okay we were laughing at my
vacuous life yeah yeah because he's 47
with no kids and he's on his way out
girl and
the 30 you're more likely to not have
children than to have children as a
woman so it's like it's more likely that
you probably will never have them
she's not happy but actually you watch
me I mean you can say whatever you want
it
yeah it's more likely or more unlikely
it does not define me no no we're
talking in general
and I'm also talking in general I just
feel that you know I I am actually it's
impossible not to take it personally
I'm actually not taking it personally
she can take it you know there are many
more women in that age and trust me I'm
still get carded when I buy wine so I
don't need to take it personally because
you know I I'm not worried about that
what like I I do agree you guys with
what you're saying anything I do right
now by myself is because I am by myself
but every day I understand that I need
to get to my goal quicker simply when I
am ready to give birth hopefully in a
year or two I can stay at home and raise
my children there is no bloody way
they're going to be nannies with my
children and I'm somewhere else that's
why I am the one who will raise my
children because only I can give them
the love that they need this is exactly
why she should give me her Instagram
because I said that two days ago I said
there's no way
let my children be be raised by some
psychopath at a [__] daycare because
you see these daycares in America where
they're putting Hulk Hands on the
children and making them have Fight Club
like literally you know what I mean like
I'm not gonna I'm like are you gonna
leave your kids with some psychopath
like I love the fact that my mom worked
so hard as a single mom and did her best
to be in my life as much as possible she
would be in her life in the daytime and
then she would work as a bartender at
night time trying to keep the lights on
as a 27 year old woman with three
children three children amazing bro you
know what I mean sell superheroes but
what you could do raising the families
and all these kids especially single
moms like I know for men they don't
really tend to go for single moons but
that aside single moms are superheroes I
see even my mom race four kids but I see
my dad a lot don't get me wrong about
just women are superheroes what they can
do that's the beauty of a man and a
woman there's a lot of stuff that men
can do when they're providing I go I
conquer the world and deal with stress
but raising a family like all these kids
on you and you've got to try and forget
all these moves once crying one needs to
feed in this napping each and then just
get on with it like the superheroes
might not you have to commend women in
that department when women are women
what they can do a man could never do
well I mean actually that's that's not
true a single fathers raise better kids
yeah the statistics if you've got if
you've got how for me personally from
what I've seen in my life I've never
seen a man deal with multiple times they
can't because they only get custody like
10 of the time but but what she's saying
is she has it is actually factually true
like no I know this I know I know I've
seen this but I'm saying this from what
I've seen I've never seen a man like
normally when I see his it was different
for me me and my um someone's most
people when he was young so I had in
three days or three days a week since he
was like one month old I had to do all
the night feeds and never changed
everything I had one child but I see a
lot of men when they have been with
their wives or the partners for a long
time and then their missus goes away for
like a weekend and the kids are running
what they don't what to do yeah they're
stressing where women just take you on
this on their shoulder that's what I'm
just saying I don't know if they've had
them and raised himself I don't know
about all of that but I'm saying is when
they've been in the relationship they're
so used to having the woman there where
the woman goes along they're just like
oh they're they're in turmoil they're
like I don't know these kids running
around and they get yeah wait for the
wife to come back yeah and I think I
think and when going back to like I do
think like from a biological standpoint
a woman's specialty and talent is
taking care of her children nurturing
them and loving like you know when we're
sick do you like want to snuggle up with
your dad no you're like you're like Mom
where are you I feel miserable you know
she's like Pat in your head like it's
okay [__] you're gonna be all right
calm down you know you you chill out you
feel good and then at the same time Dad
goes out and makes shitload of money
anything breaks in the house like Dad
can you fix this he's like all right let
me let me sort this out you know both
people mother and father have their
Specialties right how many like your
ladies were down to two uh don't you
like a guy that's handy if you're like
hey the the dryer keeps like shaking and
moving across the [__] basement can
you fix it don't you like it guys like
just give me a second I can watch a
YouTube video I can sort it out right
two points give them two
[Laughter]
that goes back to the original thing
that I personally believe in my brand is
that men and women
need to get over their [__] then you
drop their egos
come together
have a family
make good children
and make a better Society this whole
[__] we're at each other's throats
trying to tear each other apart when you
have your single girlfriends your single
guy friends are like oh just leave him
you can get a better one I swear to God
or the other side around just leave her
approach go out there and download
Tinder [__] all these hoes right so both
sides is [__] as [__] like men and
women and you know what you know why I
have a job as a dating coach you know
Billy has a job as a dating coach Troy
has a job as a date coach because men
and women they're both lost and Western
Society you think you have dating
coaches in the East they're like no if
you're dating coaches your grandmother
your grandfather that's true dieting and
relationship world is really messed up
and absolutely the the modern society
people are not prepared to compromise
and when I
I I did a survey
and I I take a survey by asking a load
of people myself personally
I anybody I I meet I said how long have
you been married over 20 25 years I said
what's your secret sauce like how how is
that possible how did you do it
and
every single time they said to me the
same word
compromise isn't that the opposite of
narcissism and ego yeah yeah right
moral Society people are not prepared to
compromise you say that some people
they're like what are you crazy how many
people you know man and woman they take
like 900 selfies and they're like trying
to like find the best one to put like a
million face app filters on to be as
good looking as possible to make
strangers on the internet happy and
these [__] end up alone
have you ever been in those situations
where you you hear someone speaking on
what they think relationships are and
then it just takes you back
because you're like wait hold on this is
what you say I think a healthy
relationship looks like takes you back
to what no not takes you back as it
takes you back all right
because there's been a few times I can't
think of head what they actually said
but there's a lot of times where someone
will say something and I'm like you
understand it's not like what
relationship relationships that's what
because everyone kind of thinks of this
like we all understand it everyone
thinks of this cookie cutter Disney
[__] end of Snow White [__] like
what are marriages they they got married
and live happily ever after but that's
not what life is well even what life is
because this women were just told we can
have everything you can be tall handsome
yeah
that is going to be faithful to you and
you're a queen and you did nothing wrong
if any of that the problem the problem
is like people what people want is the
honeymoon period you know it's the
honeymoon period isn't it it's when the
it's when the the the the
neurotransmitters are firing when that
sexual chemistry is there when that
intensity is there do you know what I
mean and that's what people think it
should be like the whole way through and
it's never going to happen which is
never going to happen so I have a
question who raise your hand if you grew
up with um two parents so like not
single mother not single father so raise
your hand two parents two oh wow
what do you mean what yes put your hand
up stronger
so so another thing is we also don't
have a model to look at because how do
you learn how to be a husband and how do
you learn how to be a wife you know what
nothing and on top of that most of the
marriages that we've seen women lead
yeah and you can look at that even in
consumer buying decisions because women
make 80 percent of consumer buying
decisions of meaning that most wives are
making all of the financial decisions
majority of I think it was and and on
top of that I also think it's when you
have a contract that one one party
is rewarded for leaving the party that
is not rewarded is always going to be
trying to make the other one happy
so this makes me want to show you guys a
video of the awesome wives that we have
to look up to so this one wife um she
was a Christian and when she was younger
she spoke about how she never wanted to
put her body on the internet right and
she she said that she doesn't understand
girls that do that she married one of
the top um Superstars she was beautiful
girl next door look
um and now she's around 30 something and
she's had the kids
and let's let's just see you know what
she's doing now
um
[Music]
I'll see if you guys know who it is
[Applause]
oh not these women I know
can you turn it down a little kid it's
kind of loud kind of loud
start it from the beginning thing
um I can't really see it
okay so so there's a guy coming in he's
attract she's taking off her wedding
ring
on national TV Haram yeah Haram
and now remember I don't know if you
guys remember Aisha Curry like 10 years
ago
yeah and okay you can stop it king um
that she wanted guys who want her
husband to like her yeah that was stupid
wait wait go to her can you pull up her
Instagram I'm pretty sure she did a yeah
yeah she did yeah yeah go go back
there's um
so and this was the Christian like girl
next door so it's like we we have wives
that are openly hitting on other men is
she still married yeah yes she is this
just adds to myself this just adds to my
point are you gonna let her do that bro
bro it's basically like cuckolding isn't
it really yeah as well it's like cucking
on live TV and because she knows she's
got a big old fat 50 payout no matter
what she does that's why I ain't leaving
can she even hit a layup no
can she dunk no for the for those who
don't know right
Aisha Curry is married to Steph Curry
the basketball player the the legendary
boss will play that everyone knows now
the reason three-time NBA champion NBA
champion three times right now this lady
came on went on the news or whatever it
was and basically said
um she was upset that more girls talk to
Steph her husband then guys talk to her
and she wants just as much of attention
from the opposite sex as her Superstar
husband gets this is the problem here
one of my biggest ex yeah is women that
love attention I eat I hate it so much
like it and you can see it yeah and I
think it's there's two there's two parts
if a woman's in a relationship I think
there's a multitude to it one is society
that's telling them that oh you have to
get attention it's just they've just
been brought up in it which I think is
just I hate that anyway I like those
private instas no no Instinct
there's hardly any
um hardly any followers it's just the
Friends the family hardly anybody
private no not half naked and I also
think men also have to I think sometimes
I'm gonna play Devil's Advocate also
because I think there's two sides to
every coin I also see a lot of the time
is men ain't making their woman feel
like she's a queen I think it's a man's
Duty and a job to let his woman know I
love you I think you're beautiful this
and that so she shouldn't have to go
outside for that but I see also it's his
duty huh this is Duty
I do see men that do that and women
still crave attention and my thing is
this if if I'm if you're only interested
in me and I'm giving you everything you
need you should not have to go to the
outside world to get fulfillment because
then it's then then it's then it goes to
another level my woman she can't be on
Instagram half naked she can't be there
looking for attention what kind of woman
wants to go out there save attention and
get lost off attention off men have you
got a man that loves
you've got to choose why is it in it 100
well and it's very fine and so if you
get burned by someone that look clearly
looks like a gold digger then it's your
own vehicle but but it's so hard for a
guy because women's are they are masters
of manipulation
I'm trying to find the quote from Aisha
in her 20s because she had um
she she said something along the lines
of like I don't understand the girls
that just take their clothes off that's
never been my style I'm not that type of
girl
um and then
um let's pull this you got to be like
LeBron James wife you know how I know
LeBron James wife is so amazing I don't
even know her name her name she's just
LeBron James wife her name's Savannah
but yeah
there we go Haram
now remember report that photo this is
the top one percent like what more could
you ask Beyond one person are you
kidding me like one of what like what
more could you ask for tall good looking
nobody hears winning an NBA championship
that's what I'm saying what comment what
more command do you you'd literally pass
everything is a good is from the outside
anyway seems like he's a very good
husband he's a good dad he's tall he's
good looking he's absolutely minted he's
very successful and if his wife's acting
like that what chance have we got how
many um times do we see these men that
have got everything and their wives are
still cheating you just think if his
wife's cheating on him watch any others
have gotten and women wonder why oh why
are you so scared to get married why do
you want prenups this and that well this
is what Society is showing us we're
logical men we see this if we can happen
to Steph Curry and other people watch us
do I have I'd like to ask that ladies a
question I'd like to ask the ladies a
question do you do you believe that
she's doing this because she that she
feels there's something missing in her
marriage or she feels that she needs
more
I think that girls start I've kind of
noticed a trend with chicks okay it's
like so in their early 20s we we compete
with our face right because we we don't
have wrinkles or like under 25. then
late 20s women tend to get in really
good shape because their face is
starting to get not that bad but like
the face is starting to go the wrinkles
are starting to come they can't compete
with the younger chicks
so then I noticed they get into really
good shape in their later 20s usually
the best shape of their life 30s come
along they start taking off their
clothes because now now they're in their
30s this is something I've noticed
there's no data behind this just so
that's what I think it's like around
like 35 women just start taking off
their clothes slowly and then as soon as
they only have their body left that's
when you see like Jennifer Aniston and
all those models just like just going
completely naked because they're trying
to be as valuable as they used to be in
the early 20s that's competition yeah
but almost like with themselves in a way
because they used to get like a certain
level of attention because you're 22
right and you got this pretty face okay
now that's starting to go you compete
with your face okay that's starting to
go now I gotta take off my clothes are
they not ashamed like you know you have
children like I mean this is this is one
thing I'm not showing anything she's
naked on TV doesn't she because she's
like she's not showing any of the sexual
that shows you how lost you are I'm
sorry I'm sorry saying it you think this
is okay this is okay for oh sorry this
is one thing I'll say yeah if you any
this is what I always say to women oh
well I can wear white do that everyone
wears a lot this is my thing for
everything I say okay then would you let
your seven-year-old daughter wear that
would you let yourself in your old
daughter take a picture of that and put
on on Instagram if no then there's a
problem with it because I would I don't
wear nothing that I wouldn't that I
think my children shouldn't wear and the
women always say did you let your
seven-year-old daughter do other things
that you do as a grown-up are you joking
that's a very different question
let her let her let her expand on that
statement wait wait go back to your
seven-year-old daughter statement go
ahead oh no I'm not gonna entertain you
guys to be honest I'm not gonna
entertain you guys in the world of logic
I shall not answering
I totally agree women should not be
that's not sexual that's not sexualized
but what I'm saying is do you have sex
with your clothes on or clothes off
uh whatever I want to do why
because her clothes are off this is what
I'm asking this question but that's why
I'm asking I always say this like if you
wouldn't let your daughter Chad help me
out then what's wrong with it and
because and it's because it's sexual so
why would you want to be sexualized if I
love you and you're my wife I want you
to look beautiful I don't want you to
look sexy yeah but she's not your wife
she has their hospitals
don't you worry too much about someone
else I'm talking about for me though I
never said her pacifically but you're
saying she's not naked she's naked you
don't need to you know she's basically
everyone's wife at this point that's
Instagram's girl you should put it out
there for everyone if you had to give
that a black or white statement is this
good for a marriage or bad for a
marriage go ahead you're on the internet
now a thousand plus people watching I'm
not gonna give you that answer that you
want I wouldn't give that answer either
yeah
you just said it yourself maybe like an
hour or two ago if you're gonna overtalk
me I'm not you can't stay okay so a
question for the men is your wife is
that okay for your wife that ain't my
wife are you [__] kidding me
is anyone okay with that for a wife Mr
female dating coach he's okay
absolutely not okay okay not okay so
then do women's opinions even matter oh
their opinions do matter but this this
is Haram this is like the Christian
what's the Christian version of Haram
that's also that this is bad in every
single religion this is not okay this
and you know what the biggest problem
about this it's not about her doing it
it makes Steph Curry look like a fool
horrible look like a fool like hey bro
hey bro I saw you missed that three
point you know what that's why your wife
posts naked photos on Instagram bro
super chats um because we just got a
bunch from Thane we've missed you where
have you been Thane is a big super
chatter in the space he says um lady
saying she is not showing anything is
beyond lost
um hashtag modern producer camera habit
fun stop it blessing I just want to read
those because those were big ones
um
Let me refresh this also guys make sure
you like the video um a like is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these live streams so um if you
like these videos and you want other
people to see them how many likes are we
at King
how many likes are real 7 17. thank you
okay 7 17 guys
um if we get to 1 000 I'm gonna I'm
gonna be nice if we get to 1100 we'll
open up the chat also do it yeah also
okay I'm gonna read the rest
umiwood 2004 we are statistics and we
are every part of Statistics also both
men and women enjoy nighttime yet these
304s behave like someone doing charity
on Flat Earth denier I agree with pearl
if each person
disregards having to worry about if
their needs are being met then that
leaves them with more time again that's
my point it's the mindset to focus on
their partner's needs being met action
out of selflessness instead of
selfishness Rob I'm a huge shout out to
all of you I've been watching this
channel for six months and it's
motivated me to go to the gym so far I
have lost 50 pounds let's do this
that's a 50 pounds amazing amazing no
more whales don't be fat whales M and J
do everything MLD it's not you it's them
truly from the last night she hesitated
about the intimacy as a choice to pick
someone you're actually attracted to and
fulfill your duties Geraldo morillo when
people love each other the sex will be
free oh I already read that one it was
wrong the last time as well
[Laughter]
um okay I have uh
uh I have one more Quest I want to find
sorry guys women others when we're Super
Chat women cheat emotionally men cheat
physically posting provocative photos of
yourself is obviously for attention
driven by emotion with that being said
how often do women cheat yeah if we if
we consider women accepting attention
from other men cheating how often do
women cheat
all the time Bailey most women a lot of
women so
I I agree with that statement it's true
women women love attention this is what
I'm saying I can't stand women that
describe of attention all the time like
he just does some attention these days
he's like crack like they I've seen some
women do the maddest things for
attention I'm just thinking what is it
like what Clark is a hell of a drug for
him no tell me tell me right whatever
scene like
I've seen like um friends Mrs is like
they just want to go out so bad but
they've got money so they're stealing
stuff out of the Jaws to try and sell it
so they can get money to go out and they
just put like they're just just the
stuff they post and the things they do
and I just think why you were so you try
you do anything you can to go out just
so you can get attention from men try
and dress the women away in less and
less and less and less because they want
attention so like so someone want to
wear something of like well she's gonna
attention let me take off even more
clothes and it's not even a good
attention because these men would let me
tell you something women just so you can
get it into your head you will get a lot
of attention off men if you dress like
hoes because we see you like that so we
might sleep with you but we're not going
to marry you get this into your head
they don't understand it they think yeah
these men want me yeah they do well
they're going to marry you is anyone
does anyone look at a woman yeah half
naked I think oh I bet she's going to be
a good one
you want to you're going to marry you
want to marry someone you want to marry
someone like you if your daughter wants
to be like if you want happy for your
daughter to be like them then you know
why would I want my daughter to dress
like that so you just like I want to add
on to that and I think it's because in
Pearl I want you to add if you think I'm
wrong or right but I think it's because
a lot of these girls they were never
really loved by their dad because when
you have that love from your father at a
young age you feel so secure in yourself
that you don't need to like post half
naked photos on Instagram because all
the girls that I know came from like
well-adjusted households which are very
rare well-adjusted households where they
respect their father and their father
was always there because remember a
woman's first masculine love in her life
is her father and if that love is
Tainted you know so is she so true and I
think right now when you have women
initiating 78 of all divorces in America
kicking the father out and does the wife
sit around like you know what your dad
was so great but I had to kick him out
she's like no your dad was an [__]
your dad abandoned you and she from a
young age is being trauma dumped on by
her mother and then she has this
negative outlook about men sales for the
rest of her life which leads her to be
this insufferable cat lady that Kevin
Samuels was dunking on you know what I
mean and that's the thing right now when
you have all these modern women who hate
Modern Men
who the majority of modern men being
raised by men or women when the majority
households are singing around the
households it is true right
you know do you do you disagree that
like a woman because you know you love
your dad and everything you feel like
you still need to go out there and get
attention and take off your clothes and
all that
um I no I don't I don't like wearing
crazy stuff
like
I think
a lot of children have not really been
raised by either of their parents
because even if they have a mother in
the house she is working
and daycare and the state spends more
time with children than the parents do
the average parent spends 30 minutes a
day how often does the kid spend on
their phone how often does the kid at
school so the school and Tick Tock is
having more influence on their your kid
than you are so now we have all these
children that are being raised by the
culture and not the family
that is very true yeah and that's what
they want when you and then if you
really want to get into it the
Rockefellers wanted that [__]
they do these things and promote it to
make a single break up the families
because then they can raise the kids to
be to the slaves that they need them to
be you can't put your worldview on them
now you're going to teach your kid that
you can chop off your dick and you can
be a girl and this and that because
you're not because the mothers are not
there yeah your dads are not there not
that who's raising the kids the state's
raising the kids and then they're
putting in their filthy dirty ideology
into your children and you don't have no
say over it not not in my house but no
chance and let me add artists so how do
I agree with kit yesterday never met
that man and now Ty here never met this
man before in my life you have some
basement on the show what is are we like
we have like a patriarchy conspiracy
Network that we're all like hey bro you
ready to impress these women bro you're
ready to like shame them you know what
kind of you know what kind of red pilled
me I was reading the writings of women
like 150 years ago about marriage and
like what they looked for in a husband
and they literally were writing about
how like you can't trust your feelings
like that won't be a really fulfilling
long-term relationship and they were
talking they were like always listen to
your husband he is the head of the
household like um they basically said
that arguing is the woman's fault
because if you tell your if you think of
it as an employee boss relationship if
you and tell your employee something and
they start arguing with you that's the
employee's fault not the boss but I was
like we don't that's not normal it's
always like you gotta compromise you're
not supposed to do that that's not what
it is
it's not what a real traditional like
marriage is if you look back at it the
problem is that marriage is a it it's
not fit for purpose in the current state
of things in the culture you know
because the cult the the state of the
culture now means that marriage as it
was is fatally challenged because people
just don't want to behave in that way
anymore and it's a real insolvable
problem unless either we go back to the
1950s or we try I don't know we try and
find another way through but it's very
different I think women these days think
that they have a big thing about no one
can't tell me what to do I do it because
I want it but really
if a man's telling you something if it's
your husband is only going to tell you
for your own good now that doesn't mean
you're his slave it just means you're
his wife and you respect him you think
this is the man that I want to lead our
family and raise my kids and help me
raise my kids if he tells you something
he's not going to be telling you he only
has your best interest at heart and I
think like now women are like you can't
tell them like do you know how many of
my friends are like oh
um my Miss is going to go to Marbella or
ibif I says what yeah well I can't be
saying nothing because I said what my my
I was with my ex on and off like
something she wouldn't even ask she
won't even enter it wouldn't even enter
her edge your message shouldn't even
want to go to them places
and that's not me being controlling I
just have standards you mean going with
their girlfriends you mean yeah yeah
going with her friends on a girl's
holiday it would never happen and it's
not even
um
like oh you're controlling you can't
tell her what to do well like I don't
tell her what to do if you want to go go
but I'm not going to be you're not
coming back to my house yeah we have we
have wives that don't see a problem with
that like we have four grown wives that
do not see a problem with going out to
the bar with their friends it's going
out to the club where they think it's
normal yeah crazy thing I've been saying
this for a while yeah I've been saying
this for a while now and it's kind of
like it's a little bit of a dark
position but you're having a generation
of women who don't know how to lead and
maintain and keep a relationship
raising women with those same break
broken standards so it's kind of like
what the church says like the
generational curse you know you have the
blind leading the blind at this point
and if there's not a big thing to step
in because
if you look at the direct
statistics whatever whatever fancy name
you want to put on of the single mother
household it is detrimental to society
single mother households it's not a dig
on women right but I was raised in a
single mother household and I had to do
so much work and so much therapy and so
much self-development I paid hundreds of
thousand dollars in self-development
stuff to get to where I am and I had to
have the discipline and desire to go
through this stuff and realize like hey
you're not doing things the way you
should be doing them you need to change
a lot of people don't want to confront
themselves a lot of people don't want to
accept the fact that you're incompetent
at this time and you need to become more
competent and you're having this
situation right now in the west
exclusively
and look at the state of the West you
can say all this [__] like all these
conservative values or blah blah blah
and this and that but are you happy with
the society you're living in all right
do you think the society that you're
living with right now is trending in the
right direction do you guys Western
Society I live in Dubai so I'm good
do you know what's crazy though what
they think is that modern developments
that they think that modern developments
and technology is more important than
family yeah and if you talk to people on
the left they literally think this
they're like well we're living longer
than ever before well you know we have a
higher you know standard of living than
ever before but it's like we have the
most broken family that we have ever had
absolutely a society of like like we
have a bunch of women that were not
raised by wives yeah that's you a point
right because I'm another one of those
raised by a single mother situations
right and if it wasn't for the fact that
I I took the time to understand
psychology of myself psychology of
people psychology of just human beings
in general I majored in Psychology to
figure out why I was so [__] up
I went from the same group of like you
have to go through these things to try
and figure out why you're so [__] up
so like now that I have an understanding
of myself and why some of the ticks that
I have I have them it's hard not to see
the beginning stage you know what I mean
so it's hard not to like look at the
situation that you're in and understand
why that you do this thing and then not
once you understand why you do it that
not be the thing that pops up in your
head all the time so it's like to put it
in context
uh your mum comes home in a single
parent household and she's always angry
when she gets home every single day
right from from work she comes back and
she's angry and she's pissed off and she
screams and she shouts at everyone now
when you get to that age you
subconsciously start doing the same
things you come home you're upset at
work you start screaming at everyone
else you start doing the same way your
mum did it and it only takes of you
realizing that probably the reason that
you're doing it the same way your Monday
is because that is what you're used to
seeing and understanding that part of
your psychology and getting away from
that is the number one step but that
also is the hardest step because people
don't want to take it because you have
to do some self self like reflection and
you have to look at the dark sides of
yourself that you don't want to see all
right yeah I think the the way in which
guys we had a Super Chat I'm gonna read
really quick
um I'm mld's mom
[Laughter]
yeah wow bringing the family and let me
just say this Ephesians 5 22 wives are
committed to our commit commanded to
submit to their husbands as they would
to Christ and to show them respect often
overlooked does that men are equally
obligated husbands are told to love
their wives as Christ loved the church
with humility and sacrifice as if caring
for their own bodies Jesus how much did
she send she sent five hundred dollars
she's a good Christian woman you know
and and that's you know like going back
to the principles of things coming
together like she's an old school
traditional Roman and she chose the path
of like trying to do in the modern woman
thing and just thought it didn't pay off
you know she was like the Amish where
you like go you like try out the sinning
you're like really this doesn't work she
came back and even when she's 27 she
completely rededicated her life to
Christ and you know like she's my you
know what a great thing too is like if
you have a good relationship as a man
with your mother run every woman you
date past your mom because your mom
loves the [__] out of you and she'd be
like this girl's hooking around because
you know your mom we know the tracks
they can see the crazy and the other
girls you know what I mean
my mother disapproved of every girl I
brought back so I don't know that's
necessary but but with all due respect
with all the respect you're going
through a divorce right now so it was
Mom correct she didn't get to meet her
but
um she passed away a while ago but but I
look back on those choices what do you
think Mom she's like no she's gonna put
a child first she's got a child already
no it's okay she's right about that
though because when you date a single
mother listen as look in this world you
look look
a woman will die for her children
literally die nobody come like what's
the number one law of the Jungle right
never get between a mother and her cups
and women will put their children women
will go into debt women will [__]
scam somebody to get the money to take
care of their children because their
children is number one you know what I
mean so if you're a man entering a
situation when you're going to date a
woman that has children you are going to
have to mentally prepare to know that
like I'm just not gonna be number one
like it's it's in her DNA to prioritize
the children
um yeah I have a child myself yeah even
I couldn't be with someone that had a
child I just I just mine's for the
simple fact mine might be for a slightly
different reason mine's for the simple
fact is there's no way on God's green
earth am I spending more time with
someone else's keep them my own and
actually this is a single parent she's
gonna have the kid the majority of the
time and I'm not spending I'm not
sneaking my son like the children
innocent or children are beautiful I
love children but when it comes to like
me having to spend more time with your
child of my own I just feel like as I I
would personally feel it's about that
I've got nothing against single moms I
think being a mother is the greatest
thing you can do in this world
absolutely however that's the reason why
I personally couldn't just
um marry someone that's already got kids
because I'm not spending more time with
your kids on my own no way it's just
hard it's just hard
yeah I've I've dated what is the
solution though because like unless
because the problem is right that
previously Society kind of kept
everything in check all right and now
it's kind of Open Season isn't it
because it's like anybody where I have
it I have it you have all the solutions
being divorce yes we're gonna ban that
ban abortion yeah yep also ban birth
control while we're at it you know I
know the men are like no no don't go
that far damn
um
an endurer
[Music]
there's a great book by a man named
Cameron Haynes you know what the name of
that book is
indoor it is a great book fantastic
books that should be the name of your
book that's bad news for you man it's
okay you see how you said that obviously
the antidote would be to ban divorce
yeah but in extreme cases because I do
see this
um happen a lot
um for women where they'll try but then
the men might be beating them up and
stuff like this like because sometimes
there's a lot of pieces of [__] out
there anyone are coming home and put
your hand on your wife you're a piece of
[__] yeah and if if I luckily none of my
friends are out there if I saw any of my
friends going home and beating the
misses I'll put man's on him I don't
agree with that especially the movie of
your children you're a sick individual
even if she's in you it's not an excuse
well so if they're in a situation where
if then if they're in a situation if
they're in a situation where they're
gonna be how hard did she hit him you
know it's different don't get me wrong
I'm not saying I was like grab a chair
getting hit and hit him back at two
different things
don't get me wrong if I was out on out
somewhere maybe a bar or something and a
girl randomly punched me in my face when
I slap her back maybe but that's
different I think if you know this woman
you have love for this woman it's just
hitting you bro you're a man but just
move out the way there's other ways to
go about it if my mom hit me I'm not
gonna hear back you know what I mean I'm
not gonna turn around and hit my mum
back so if you're someone that you love
and you know it's different to some
random stranger in the street and then
women will say oh yeah but you're a man
you're a lot stronger than me I'm a lot
stronger than most men if they hit me
I'm watching they're not hit them back
either like come on bro like don't put
your hand on me I wouldn't hit it like
she was a man but we should get a little
slap back here probably yeah and I I
want to agree with tywood he said here
because I think too like everybody wants
to talk [__] and everybody wants to be
like yeah you should do this but like
when you get hit biologically as a human
your defenses are like yo defend
yourself because we're not trying to die
you know what I mean and so if you might
and going back to what I said to and I
mentioned this on jededia billa's
channel over on valuetainment I said hey
you know what I think too because I'm
all about working and out and I said if
there's one instance of either side
hitting each other and I'm not talking
like Mike Tyson knockout like uppercut
knock her out you know no short you can
nothing like that but if you know if
you're drunk and your your girl slaps
you and you push her away and she falls
down I think that you should both look
at the situation
and be like listen we're both [__]
yeah we both shouldn't have done that
okay because
people are flawed individuals
and expecting two imperfect people to
come together
like the only perfection in this life is
either death or God that's the only
Perfection and so the thing is the
people from the sidelines they like to
cast stones upon people
who are in these in situations but the
reality is
if you're too broken in Perfect People
how the [__] do you expect to have a
Flawless relationship like Troy was
saying earlier a relationship has highs
a relationship has the lows and if your
husband is jumping off top ropes and
giving you a people's elbow like in the
middle you gotta go clearly but if
there's a mistake making like why are we
just so
quick
to crucify people in relationships
who may have made a mistake because
everybody in this panel you all got
skeletons in your closet because you're
humans all right everybody here got
skeletons in your closet and if that
[__] was outed to the whole world you'd
be embarrassed but it is what it is
because we're all flawed broken humans
and I'm just saying that we need to go
beyond our Brokenness as humans and
emulate godlikeness and try to come
together and create this [__] Gap
that you know come close the gap thank
you very much close the gap and
endure
[Laughter]
we are going to close out the show
um guys I'm saying they've enjoyed
enough
my patience has just I've been doing
this for a year I will not be over
talked on my own show so yeah I'm sorry
I had to kick out a girl today
um but final thoughts um starting here
go around in the second row you guys can
put any social media anything you got a
thousand dollars towards that kickout
camp today yeah
I think YouTube takes like 30 30 God
damn it Susan yeah yeah
it's probably right
like like six seven hundred but but guys
I appreciate it I'll text my mom
okay final thoughts go ahead
oh well thank you for having me it was a
pleasure to I don't know to share my my
opinion I also hear opinions of others
it's sometimes it's very nice to agree
to disagree because I believe that any
knowledge should be shared and just
because you don't believe or think about
like someone else doesn't make you and
he lasts it's just nice you know you're
one of the few women who endured to the
end of these shows just saying uh I mean
I'm not gonna lie it did feel a little
bit like at times uh I was uh but to be
honest I I enjoyed that actually I was
thinking I don't really spend much time
with men I'm like spending most of my
time with myself or with my girls so
actually being in the company of a man
who have a very strong opinion since uh
it's nice so yeah
um yeah
uh yeah thank you so much for having me
pal it was a definitely unique
experience a bit unfortunate about my
friend uh having to leave but otherwise
the the conversation was stimulating and
uh really enjoyed it you can catch me on
Instagram as a dating success coach and
uh I'll be tuning in again for sure
what's your Instagram
Instagram is dating success coach
he told you
right now
as always thanks for having me Paul
um I mean a lot was covered today is
seems like common sense but at least
it's reiterated to everyone that doesn't
have common sense so uh
um and also get your beard right beard
gang members
yeah thank you for having me I I
actually had quite a lot of fun here I
like to hear different people's
perspectives and I also feel like no
matter what you can always learn from
somebody and you can always take a
different perspective we've all come
from different cultures countries and
backgrounds so everyone has a different
opinion because there's ways differently
um you can catch me at Instagram at Thai
Mitchell Ty Mitchell official
[Music]
literally at the pre-sale launch right
now
um I'm not personally someone that knows
a lot about crypto but I know all the
crypto people in Dubai they've all
invested heavily into this going so get
it at the public pre-sale my boy and
ride J Ryan j e um does e-commerce so go
on my Instagram if you want to do
e-commerce there are a lot of changing
lives they're literally turning people
into millionaire so get them yeah that's
it thank you for having me thanks for
coming good
if you want to learn how to endure
[Music]
if life has been tough to you as a man
and you are struggling with depression
anxiety or you just need a digital
Community to help you out on June 29th I
am launching the inner game healing
Summit endure go to Inner
gamehealing.com read what we have there
get on the waiting list because we have
a five-day enrollment and then starting
July 10th we'll be doing a five day
virtual Workshop that will teach you the
principles are enduring through the hard
times in life including a video course
and a year-long telegram chat with over
250 members already presently in the
chat to help you in your journey of a of
achieving good mental health
[Laughter]
uh yeah as a chronic overthinker and a
general everyday to days and this was
fun uh overthinking with a bunch of
other people and getting everyone's
points of view was fun uh like I always
say when I come on here and things like
this I don't really use social media but
you can follow me if you want all right
the underscore Franklin one I might post
pictures once every six months
so yeah
jump jump on board for that
all right so two so two things uh don't
get married get possible go to Colombia
go to Mexico have a good time we're all
gonna be dead soon so let's party uh but
if you do get married
one word
you can say prenup yeah well that is
what two words
um and uh follow me on all socials at
real Troy Francis for dating coach
wisdom thank you okay guys I'm gonna
read the rest of the Super Chat so it
says my Indian colleague went to go on a
visit with her friends leaving her 18
month old baby with her husband Rola was
right the culture is messed up 18 months
wait leaving her it's I'm confused is he
saying that like in India it's a messed
up or it's messed up everywhere I'm not
sure the husband probably wasn't doing
chores so it's okay
they will literally argue you should get
divorced over chores he left the dishes
in the dishwasher what an [__] okay
who cares pickle Rick um women cheat
emotionally men cheat physically posting
profile I read that one already okay
um okay guys a couple announcements
before we on the show as you already
know two clips channels just pearly
clips and pro daily also
um sign up for the fourth tier um to get
a one-on-one call with me once a month
you know some call me I call myself a
YouTube genius you know
um you are and I did get a million
subscribers in a year and 1.5 in a year
and a half so I am pretty good at
YouTube you know whatever you know the
critics and detractors will say what
they want but most of them can't do what
I did so so sign up for that tier also
guys uh my Instagram just probably
thinks one go follow wife School
subscribe to uh we want to get to 30 000
subscribers on wife school and let me
know in the comments what we should do
um for the next wife school like the
video on your way out and we'll we'll
talk to you next time
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
what's going on people King Richie is
back again with another podcast good
evening and hi and welcome to Auntie
Jenny's Village podcast it's your boy
The Fresh Prince of someone
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how can
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men like
I'm not saying you have to be submissive
to every old waste man walking around
I'm just saying that it would be
femininity would be in your nature
breaking it is to find somebody you're
compatible with that you'd like not just
of your same generation and that likes
the same things that you do going out
having fun get out okay okay then then
get out then get out after after then
get out I'm not here to get canceled
today most men want a woman that has
some degree of femininity where they
feel like they're taken care of taking
care of I'm 99 I'm submissive and you'd
be surprised because I will say what I
want to say now and I'll say what I want
to say with my mind but my demeanor
doesn't change and I'm gonna look down
on him because at the end of the day
whoever you're with is a reflection of
you what has happened in society that
has made the normal man a waste man I
would
asking a guy to buy like a three
thousand dollar bag now he's
foreign